Okay, that's great. That's just fantastic. Is there anything
else over >> Well, I thought we're having a >> Gotcha.
Love you, buddy. Anything else? Doesn't Destiny literally show
his DMs with Sockdown Incel, who has an account on Kiwi Farms?
They, you know, they're not in there because you've been corrected.
You've definitely seen the update that they got all got deleted
and the person got permabanned. This is just a lie. This is just
a blatant lie. >> Being too mean. That's not a critique.
Hold on. If my friend was being too mean to me and I tell him
that he's being too mean, is that not a critique? That is you
critiquing them. Quean being mean to someone else is not Queman
critiquing someone else. That is the claim that you
>> I crying. Yeah. Like it's actually like it's so
complete. Oh. >> Oh, you're talking complet.
>> Okay. Unfortunately, there have been several developments
in the Willy Mack
illiteracy drama. Okay. the the shocking fact that the YouTuber
Willie Max Show is completely illiterate. He cannot read. He
cannot comprehend hypotheticals. Any conditional hypothetical
is beyond the understanding of
young William. Okay,
there's been some developments. There is some fantastic developments.
Okay, apparently Destiny went live today and started literally
discussing how he told Willie basically the entire narrative
about Queen and I. like the whole thing,
which just seems wild to me. I don't really believe it, but I've
gotten clips linked to me with these titles. I've not seen them
yet. Okay, I've actually not seen them, but I It appears to me
that this is what has happened. Okay,
give me a quick second. We'll check this out. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay.
I messaged him and I said, "No clue how active you are in these
communities or how much you follow this stuff. I think this might
have been after >> I mean we all saw exactly what this
was from the very beginning, right? So that Oh, there's the Uncle
Nick guy that was here a little while ago in DG chat. >> We
got dogs in July 21st and then I sent him this screenshot. Why
is coming after Willie Mac? He's a total but I'm not actively
going after him right now. Just commenting occasionally signaling
to his uh fan base. You
Bro, my Discord doesn't even like me. What the are you saying?
Signaling to my fan base. If this is signaling to my fan base,
what the are you doing when you go and paste all of the Pisco
clips when you go and complain about Pisco for hours in your
chat? You see about Pisco for hours? If you think this is signaling,
you're you're putting a mark on this guy's forehead and telling
a a firing squad to start.
Are you serious? You said he couldn't form agency. You come for
his throat. This might be I don't know if this is spicy chat
or if it's justical Discord server. Um, he said he couldn't form
agency. You come for his throat. He's legitimately illiterate.
Why? Why be pranking someone about to go to jail? Uh, no. No.
False. No. Um, >> fantastic screenshot. Fantastic screenshot.
Amazing screenshot. >> So, I sent him a message on July
21st. I said, "No clue how to be in these community stuff." I
sent him the screenshot and then I said, "But people like Jessica
will amplif Oh, so he sent So, he's sending Willie Mac the screenshot
of me saying he's
uh fight docsis from places like Kiwi Farms or people like Banana
and others like Queen will make sure everyone else they can reach
like Auggie, Dioro, etc. falls in line. Uh be careful maybe.
That's what I said. I I mean like but I feel like almost even
in this video you've admitted to like grabbing from Kiwi Farm.
>> Uh hold on. What is this? What is this? What is this?
Anonymous. Thank you for the gifted sub. Thank you. Thank you.
In this video, you've admitted to grabbing from Kiwi Farms. The
same you grabbed for your Kiwi for your Keeles's manifesto. As
in, if there's archive information that is available that you
find there that is useful for you for some piece you're doing,
then yes, information is information. There is no such thing.
The genetic fallacy is just that. It's a fallacy. You cannot
say that me watching a clip of Destiny that's posted on Kiwi
Farms is somehow hurting Destiny more. That's not true. That
doesn't exist. You are wrong.
All of you guys talked to each other. You literally talked earlier
in this video about pressuring another guy. I don't even remember
the guy's name, to make videos about um this and that he turned
around and didn't do it. Do I have to go watch the whole thing?
I didn't watch this video yet from Queenman. I think I thought
it was just his statement and an edited thing put
Oh, we might have to we might have to go back and check this
whole thing out. I don't want to. >> Like you like you
guys you're in everybody's chats. I mean like you just opened
a screenshot of me. Dude, Destiny Destiny is in other chats,
namely mine where the equipment is. What are we >> The
previously public information that this is the case because just
now, just within the last hour or two, Ogie appeared on Chud's
stream. Now, one of the things that Willie said about Ogie Oh.
And then I sent him another message on July 23rd. I said, I don't
know how much you keep tabs on spicy chat, but a lot of these
people will say that they quote unquote disavow when they're
Oh, there's no way this is what he's referring to. Pressured
the guy to remove Willie Max docs. That's the proof of coordination.
Hey, Clipper who clips my content. Hey, just so you know, uh,
you accidentally posted a clip of me where docs information is
briefly available. I didn't notice it, so you didn't notice it,
but we should we should censor that. We should take that down.
That's apparently the coordination meant to with Destiny. That's
the narrative shaping. Uh-huh.
Okay, sure. Communities do people and stuff and that's quote
unquote true in so far as they will kind of laugh and say it's
not allowed just so they don't get in trouble. But they fully
participate in places where people are always doing that [__]
and they're always laughing along with it and not saying anything
to stop it. So just show the proof of that. Oh my god. We certain
certainly we have proof of this, right? Certainly we have proof
that there's a community that doxes people like significantly
all the time, right? And that Queen and I hang out there and
laugh along. Surely this wouldn't be a community I am currently
banned from, right? Surely not. Uh, and then I give two screenshots
of
um this is from spicy chat. This these messages might still even
be in there. I don't even know where they're just like posting
pictures of
like No, they you know they're not in there because you've been
corrected. You've definitely seen the update that they got all
got deleted and the person got permabanned. This is just a lie.
This is just a blatant lie. >> Bad empanada really is the
left's Nick
Bad but not as funny as doesn't need to post stuff like this.
He's an army that does it for him. That's the shimoo guy. So
Willie did just take Destiny's talking points and make a video
out of him. Yes. Yes. Willie is a Willie hears Destiny speak
and he goes, "Oh, that's just true. Destiny said something. He
told me this. There's no evidence." Okay, maybe there's this
screenshot of Spencer doing this in spicy chat which Chad immediately
addressed and perma banned Spencer for.
Right. I believe Spencer himself realized how bad it was and
deleted the message himself.
Like almost immediately after it was posted, a bunch of people
went, "Whoa, what the [__] are you doing?" And he
deleted it, right? And then he got permab banned.
>> And they're just posting pictures of I guess one of
these people is supposed to be um Willie Mac's wife now. Mrs.
>> Uh these aren't these are just random Israeli children.
None of these are Willie Mac Show gets to look at this whenever
she pleases. And you're complaining. Fine. This is the last time.
Bottom shelf. Like all these guys. Um yeah, they all do this.
It's like, >> well, the funny thing about this pens of
goat is I believe at some point here, doesn't Destiny literally
show his DMs with sock dem who has an account on Kiwi Farms?
Is that not the case that he literally has a chatter who feeds
him talking points, feeds him information that explicitly has
their own named account on Kiwi Farms? Is there any is there
any is there any consistent principle here at all? or so he either
shows them on stream, Neoy, or Sock posts them. One of the two,
but we've seen the DMs. I've seen the DMs somewhere. I don't
remember where at this point. >> And then, wait, Willie
said they got that pick wrong. Those were random girls. Okay.
Well, I I mean, it's not Well, I mean, they were trying to then,
but I guess they just [__] up. >> Okay. Apparently,
apparently Sock Apparently Whoops. Sockdown Incel posted them
himself.
>> Oh, these are his uh these are his messages with Destiny.
He posted them himself. So that's a while ago. Thought you would
start doxing people again tonight. You edged me. If you ever
decide to go scorch earth again, keep in mind Mr. Girls docs
has been public for a while. Oh, so he just has open DMs with
this guy. Doesn't have this guy blocked. Just open DMs where
he has responded to this guy. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool. So Destiny is the person who coordinates
with people on Kiwi Farms. Destiny is the person who doxes. Every
accusation is projection from him. Okay, he's just projecting.
That's it.
>> Like he's actually he's actually just totally like a
totally degenerate loser who like he's going to flame out from
this, right? I don't know. Like he won't die as a streamer, but
his credibility will be totally shot. Like he is just transparently
lying right now. Transparently creative writing. He's doing fanfiction.
Okay. He's basically writing
Fifty Shades of Gray for his own behavior. Okay. He's Twilight
and he's writing Fifty Shades of Gray about other people. weirdo.
Okay, gigga weirdo
>> streaming primarily due to the harassment and doxing
he is receiving from Salvo Pancakes. Now I saw Stardust. I was
about to call something else but I won't. I saw Stardust quote
tweeting or tweeting out um what does or think of Queen associating
with Salvo after Salvo his mom.
>> We got a we got a sub. We got a donation. We got a sub.
We got a donation. What is that? [__] I can't see
it. Hold on. Ah, I lost it. God damn it. Uh anonymous. Thank
you for the gifted sub.
>> First of all, me and Salv are very good friends already.
Okay, first of all, so don't even attempt to drive a wedge like
that cuz we were very friends already. And I'm also very good
friends with Ougi, just to be totally clear. Just be clear, we're
all very good friends actually. Now, what I will say is despite
Willie Mack alleging that Salvo doxed or his mom or whatever,
and while I'm sure Salvo, I do believe, sorry I shouldn't say
I'm sure, I believe Salvo has doxed people by revealing the phone
numbers before. >> Oh, I also sent this to >> Hold
on. Yeah. So, Willie Willie got sent the screenshot from Chud's
Discord by Destiny.
Did Willie think that Destiny had sent him a screenshot from
Queenman's Discord? There's no way he would have without checking
just alleged
that that screenshot from Chud's Discord that everybody knew
was from Chud's Discord, that Destiny on Twitter himself said
was from Chud's Discord. There's no way he would have thought
that that's from Queen's Discord and just run with that and said
it, right? There's a 0% chance that he would have just taken
what Destiny said. Oh, this is proof Queman part Queman's doing
this and taking that Spencer screenshot. If there's any chance
that that happened, Willie need Willie cannot be trusted anymore
at all. Willie is a completely
Yes, he's he's I
do you think Destiny might have said it was from spicy chat and
Willie was just like, "Oh, I saw a queen name and uh I can't
read that other spiky [__] I don't know what spiky
is and just run with the queen thing." I don't know. You have
all of Kiwi Farms amplifying attacking as well and stuff like
this. The queen/istical crowd all work together with them inside
Discords and stuff. And then this is one of the posts that I
sent where
>> I know it's probably kind of gay/ lazy to just post
straight up queen clips, but he's probably the best we've got
in terms of anti-felture representation. Not in the thread. Jessical
is decent at making arguments as well, but unfortunately is pretty
easy for Destiny to poison the well towards because of the cherry
connection and is also kind of too much of a moral. Queen debunks
the pix he sent the Whoa. Disavow uh disavow
to claim
Hutch. So he's just going to pull this up. This is the thread
that's apparently really bad to amplify, right? This the thread
that's really bad to amplify that he started doxing everybody
else because they amplified it, right? And now he's just like,
"Oh, I'm going to dox everybody. I don't care anymore." This
this guy's in total freef fall meltdown in the process. This
is the third time she's meed. such an obvious attempt to poison
the well against her to his audience by making it seem like it's
just part of a reoccurring cycle she engages in because she's
mentally ill. Even if there is a cycle he can point to accusations
crime reporting crime to the police isn't anything close to any
past instances he's referencing for it to be a part of whatever
pattern of behavior he thinks if you're ever wondering like where
like the um queen or this is just true. Wait, hold on. Contend
with what he just said. Is he is he actually just going to go
this is on Kiwi Farm so I don't want to take it seriously? That's
actually a fantastic point when he goes after Cherry because
Cherry reported him to the cops, right? That's insane. He is
Cherry's not like spreading. She's not leaking. She's just gone
to the cops. Why won't he contend with that point? Why is he
acting like this point is somehow bad because it's written by
a Kiwi Farms poster.
He He doesn't engage with that whatsoever. Justical talking points
come from for stuff at least related to me or people around me
about me. It always No, all of these talking points. All of these
talking points are from us. Well, sorry, not all. I think basically
if there's good points, it doesn't matter where those good points
came from, right? If I I I can't recall a point I've taken from
Kiwi Farms been like, "Oh, this is really good." But if there
was, I wouldn't be sh ashamed to take it. Right? If there's a
point like this, this is a fantastic point when he when he tries
to compare this to like Lav or or Anavar threatening to leak
his Those aren't the same thing. That's not even close. This
is just a good point. These talking points exist on KF. Therefore,
they are bad. This is another Keful's talking point, by the way,
the genetic fallacy thing. Anything coming from Kiwi Farms is
bad. If they say something bad about me on Kiwi Farms, it is
false. This isn't true. It is objectively not true. Contend with
the points as they're made. Don't try to say, "Oh, this is really
bad. Well, they they clearly take everything from Kiwi Farms."
If I was going to take some unhinged skits theory from Kiwi Farms
and start propagating that, he might have a point, >> right?
If Destiny himself,
>> okay, anonymous, thank for the gifted sub. If Destiny
himself had not said to me in my DMs, while I didn't check her
age, and if she's under 18, I'm If he hadn't said that to me
directly, I wouldn't be talking about it, right? But he said
that to me directly that he did not verify her age, that he wasn't
100% sure, that he thought she was, but he didn't verify. And
now, [__] if she's really actually a minor, I'm So
anyway, uh yeah, I I can't believe he's just dude, he How do
you go from two years ago writing a whole manifesto saying exactly
how and why these t these exact points he's making now are horrible
and
then you go and you start making those same horrible points yourself,
just transparently trying to get your audience to follow you
like a cult. It's >> Always originates uh here
uh first. But yeah, this is like they Yeah, I like it's just
so funny that Queen's like I don't know. I I have no idea what
>> Sabo didn't do. So >> Queenman didn't say he has
no idea. Quan said he's perfectly fine taking archival information
from Kiwi Farms. Why is Queen getting all the credit? Um Quimman
right now has a YouTube presence, so his stuff's way more accessible
and he's making great points. And Queman, not only that, but
Quimman was named primarily by Willie Mack. Like Quimman's making
fantastic points in this whole video. He's making fantastic points.
So that would be one reason. And then obviously Willie Mack named
him directly. Anyway, continue. >> As far as I'm aware,
>> what Salvo did was Salvo took a photo from ARI's main
Twitter timeline, his public content creator timeline of Orgie
and his mother. >> The the cross exchange of information
is actually so much that if you read the people in my thread,
they even type the same. They they all started doing like Kelly
Gene does it. >> Exclamation points exclamation.
I've been tweeting like that forever. Concerning. Very shocking.
I've tweeted like this forever. Um, hold on. Let me let me go
to my Twitter, but from an incognito window, so only the big
tweets come up. One second. Let me let me go look at this real
quick. Here's a tweet about Keeles from February 2024.
I, now that I think about it, I got to talk like this sometimes.
Just wait until Muda hears about the bathtub hormones with lollycon
packaging from Brazil that Keles was shilling to miners.
Exclamation point. This is him saying this is a part of Kiwi
Farms. I was literally I was literally DJ of the year at the
turn of this this year, right? After this year that's going to
happen after this tweet, right, for the year 2024, I am DJ of
the year and I type like this. I've always typed like this. Okay.
So, he is going to try to convince you that the way I type is
like Kiwi Farmsesque is baffling. The way I've always typed >> and
everybody the way they do the exclamation mark stuff on >> Yeah,
there like random sentences that they type. Like this should
be embarrassing. I can find you examples of me doing this. Why
was Destiny's like biggest quote unquote biggest fan? Right.
He also does like the thing. Oh, they talked about me being No,
no. I said you're But that's a totally different thing that everybody
in commentary has been doing for a long time now. There's views.
You're totally rigged right now. I told I tell him after the
Apple River bet in April of
yeah, you're raped right now. I'm not at all. He says, "Okay,
it's just making it >> Like they they everybody or a lot
of the people in my uh thread started like typing that way, too.
It was just funny like like it's so obvious the >> Yeah,
they might watch because people Queman or I would be people you're
targeting. Yeah, you talk about us all the time. He focuses on
my stream all the time. My community all the time. Yeah, of course.
I'm sorry. Your thread is obsessed with you. They're not obsessed
with me. They're obsessed with you. But they might watch my stream
if I'm covering one of your things and they might type or talk
the way I do. That's not my fault. That's not Queen's fault.
Doesn't mean it goes the other way. You can't just blame us because
they watch us talk you. That's Grand Canyon. Salvo posted a short
making fun of mother and the way she looks with a green screen
background on a short and then did a live stream talking about
how he wants to [__] his mom and all this. That stream
is honestly one of the funniest things I've ever seen. And I
I don't you might hate me saying that. I love Ogie, but that
stream is genuinely one of the funniest things I've ever seen.
It was actually insanely funny. I watched it like I don't know
a year ago maybe. Stupid funny. Just stupid funny unfortunately.
Hate to say it. Hate to say it but yeah. So Willie, you know
I understand it's not popular to stick your neck out and say
Salvo's being slandered here. Well, he kind of just did. He kind
of just did. You can't just repeated doxing claims. I don't know
if it do. Apparently has called it doxing in the past, but just
repeated doxing claims without any evidence. And they seem to
be just from what I know. Like it's just totally absurd. But
it doesn't stop there because Orgie on Chad's stream said Willie
is completely misrepresenting that conversation because what
actually happened is a month ago, a couple months ago, Orie and
Willie had a private I think we're past the Willie part where
Desi basically says I'm the one who is sending all this stuff
to Willie, right? I think we're past that. Um, dude, is Nicholas
going to like just ignore this? That Willy's only source for
this is a screenshot from Chud's Discord. Is he going to ignore
this totally or
why why is nobody able to call this out? There's just no way
that all of these people are this right that like we we can't
call this out. We can't see like, oh, it's a screenshot from
Chud's Discord that's being used to blame me and Quebin, dude.
Counter points. Come get your boy. Counter points. Your boy is
losing it. Come get him. >> Cool.
Where Willie was venting some of his frustrations, his fears,
his worries about getting aped all over social media, about getting
aped in the replies about about just get getting aped all over
the apr.
Aped and torn us under. Willie was actually venting his frustrations
about this to Ogie.
And Orgie in an attempt to commiserate and empathize and you
know be on Willy's level said, "Oh yeah, man. It was rough for
me as well when I was going through that selfo." >> Okay.
I don't know. There might be more here. I would have to go dig
more into this. Okay.
The all I wanted to watch was him basically showing that he is
just that Willie is totally minded by him. Okay. Willie is like
And the funny thing is is hey, I talked to Queen occasionally.
I haven't talked to Queen significantly. His sleep schedule is
totally different than mine right now. That's why he doesn't
come around stream. Like he is he is getting up probably like
four or five hours before me right now. Um so I don't I haven't
talked to him in weeks on a consistent basis at all. We used
to hang out in VC quite often. Uh not recently.
And but even if even if we did talk in VC, the whole thing is
like what can you prove? What do you know? Right? What do you
have proof for? That's like how we talk about things. It's not
like what narrative can we write? That's not any of it, right?
It's more explicitly like, "Hey, it's me going, hey, I'm like
under a lens right now. What do you think of like this argument
or something?" That would be like the height of it and then debating
or something. That's like that's the most conversations or it's
one of two things. It's either that or
we just play video games with like a video playing or something
like comment on it at the same time. That's like that's what
it used to be. It's not even Destiny related videos. >> You
know, it can really get you. I get it, man. I get it, man. Who
cares if selflanded? very easy position to take. >> Okay,
I'm I'm pretty I'm pretty done with this, but I do want to watch
that dicker food shops debate cuz I just think it's fun to watch
to watch food shops get totally destroyed.
>> Cry victim in a completely incoherent way. The rest
of the arguments in the
I need Dicker stream. Where's Dicker's stream? Okay, I cannot
get Dicker stream to pop up in another tab. Uh, dickers.
Can I get the dicker stream from today? Live stream VODs updated
today. Debating Destiny's number one sleeve is the dickers title.
Let's go. Where do we get food shops joining? There's morale
after morale. I think it's near the end of the stream, right?
Yeah, it is. Yeah, it is. Who's this? Is Kath He brought Kathy
in for some reason. Why is Kathy on the stream? Desty said to
Willie that Queman and JTO spread doc/leaks. Desty claims that
Queman will show Kiwi Farms clips. Desty does the same. Max Striker
don't know is an obvious joke. Sure, sure, sure. He's getting
points, getting talking points here. I think I could just off
the cuff like super outdebate somebody who's like wanted to argue
on this. It's like you're so clearly in the wrong. If you support
the Willie video, if you support Destiny's narrative, you're
so clearly in the wrong. You're so clearly incapable of supporting
your own thoughts that you are easily embarrassed by anybody
who has even a like a tangential understanding of the
>> Okay. I'm not asking people to [__] brigade
her chat. Jesus. All right.
Granny can be let let in for two. >> Oh, sure, sure, sure.
I saw I saw Ralph also debated Dicker or sorry, Ralph also debated
food shops. And if food shops didn't know to go brush up if you're
ever going to debate this again, that's embarrassing because
Ralph skull them like badly. Like they looked they looked totally
incapable of arguing anything they claimed to believe. So I would
imagine if they didn't go brush up, but then they're going to
go talk to Deckers about this. That doesn't make as much sense
to me. Hello.
Hello. Hello.
>> Oh man. >> What's up Kenny? How's it going? >> Are you
going to lose this man, man? We shot I'm not going to lose to
food chops. Hey, dude. It's uh it's just going to be funny. We'll
see. How's it
>> I'm just saying that totally dunked on her. I don't
know if you watched Mau debate. And this one I would imagine
this one's going to be similar cuz they got embarrassed by Morau.
That's not true. Gentle whale. That's not true. That's not true.
>> Food shops.
>> I am doing fine. You're my favorite. You have curly
hair, right? >> Me? I'm not.
>> I do look like it. >> Yeah, but you look you look
like a Yeah.
>> he doesn't. That's not curly hair, right? I don't think
that's curly hair. >> Okay. I think usually we like to
uh we like to say a person, right? You wouldn't say a black or
a gay, would
>> I would say that. >> Mhm. I would say, >> you
know what? This is way better than Fu's uh arguments last night.
Huh. Aiden, Dickers, Queenman. It seems like all the people against
Destiny are
That's actually way more convincing than any argument I've seen
her form so far with regards to the Willie Mac video or the Destiny
doxing campaign. >> Say that. Yeah. >> Okay, fair
play.
>> I was talking to a bigot. Jesus Christ. All right. >> Okay,
bigot. >> Yeah. What's up? >> How's it going on that?
>> Um I've heard you've had some some spicy takes recently
revolving the whole the Destiny doc stuff. >> Um yeah.
Okay. Um, so you think that >> he spent two years defending
them and he's getting backstabbed by the tribe. Dude, it's just
free. It's like so free. And all of the people who try to defend
this are going to be totally embarrassed there. Nobody will defend
this after watching the food shop. Like they will dodge everything
on this. Like at some point, does Wick not offer to host a panel
on this? Like, hey, the doxing gotten insane. It's getting like
tons of views on all of this. Wouldn't you invite Destiny to
come defend his ideas?
Like, by the way, this is why Destiny won't take debates on this
at all. He won't take debates on this because he will get thoroughly
embarrassed. Thoroughly embarrassed. The only tactic they have
is to try to do this. Try to say, "Oh, well, it's defensive,
doxy, and it's justified." And never take criticism. Never talk
to anybody about it because you will get blown the out. It is
an embarrassing point to try to argue given any of his past positions.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I was inviting you to go ahead, but
go on. >> Oh, wait. Actually, no, hold on. I I want to
ask a clarifying question first. >> Um, so do you believe
Destiny when he says that he spent over 300,000 on the lawsuit
so far? >> Yeah. Like do you want to extend that as a premise?
>> Um, Destiny's Destiny's lawsuit defense.
>> uh, if he said I would believe like 200k for sure. Andrew
Breler's incredibly expensive. That's like what he's known for.
Andrew Brettler is like the most expensive. It was probably of
Destiny to get Andrew Breler. Uh I mean he said he said I don't
have any reason,000 on it.
>> So I guess I guess one question I kind of want to ask
you is like you think Destiny deserves punishment, right? Like
for what he has done.
>> Sorry. I about Destiny's Destiny's docting allegations.
Wait, Destiny deserves punishment. >> Yes, I I understand.
I understand. I promise it's relevant. I promise it's
>> Um that's not punishment enough. No. Destiny's choice
to to get an extremely expensive lawyer is not a form of punishment,
right? He could have probably been at like what 50k right now
with a normal lawyer, just a normal Miami based lawyer, >> but
he went to the most expensive one. That's not I can believe 300.
Oh, maybe with everything. Maybe with everything. >> So,
you think that he deserves punish? >> Wait, also why do
you believe he has a criminal attorney, Penub? What are you talking
about?
>> Right. For what he's done.
>> like morally speaking, right? This is a moral debate
after all, right? >> Well, it's just a debate over Destiny's
doctoring. I don't think it's a moral debate over >> Yes.
Yes, we will lead up to it. We will lead up to it. Okay. Yes,
I know. >> Can we start with that? I This feels like a
huge diversion.
>> Okay. Yeah. Fine. Okay. So, I basically think I basically
think >> Sure, Peanut. That's true. But I don't know if
he's hired an attorney there. I don't know what's going on.
>> Yeah. Anyway, >> that if Okay, I thought maybe
you do something. Maybe you said something. All right, but you'll
understand why I brought it up. Okay, it feels as though that
if people are going after Destiny's career, like this is his
livelihood and they don't believe like any kind of punishment
is reasonable enough. Like for example, I've heard like Purple
Perry Gaming say like, "Oh, $50 million is like necessary, right,
in order to Yeah, Perry did a little shortinger in that debate
with food shops. That was I think he could have you can be serious
or you can not be serious but mixing the two is uh
but it is parry. So
that at that point you're just basically telling me yeah you
won't ever stop covering Destiny in a negative way until you
achieve total Destiny destruction right because the thing is
is that >> they're just projecting my thing onto dickers
for no reason. Uh I don't feel like spending a lot of money on
your defense of it wasn't that bad actually is a punishment.
>> It's not it's not a punishment. You hired the most expensive
thing. Sorry I cut you off, Kenny. What were you >> You
and Dickers hang out in spicy chat. Aren't you guys like friends?
>> I'm banned from spicy chat. What are you talking about?
>> I'm not in Man. >> Uh-huh. Apparently, we go and
laugh at people getting doxed in there. For sure. For sure. For
sure. For sure. >> Uh, you know, if if what Chud logic
has leaked is real, right? And I don't see any reason you don't
believe it's to be real. JT said, "Yeah, my goal is TDD or total
destiny destruction." Yes, I acknowledge it's a meme term. However,
they're kind of unironically doing it, so it's less of a meme
term, right? >> I literally spend most of my stream covering
stuff that's not this. I respond to the Destiny. That's been
the way it's been for a while now. I don't know. I don't know
why we have to pretend otherwise. >> The thing is is that
like at this point, if people are going after your career non-stop,
the equivalent of like calling your workplace and like phoning
your boss or something like that to get you fired from the job.
[__] >> Oh, do kid. This is true. Yeah, >> this
is uh this is why um this is why I think President Sunday said
something like, "Hey, um I think President Sunday asked me. He's
like, "Do you think you're safe?" Like he wanted to kill the
DOS kid and you you're like probably like more of a thorn in
his side. He's definitely losing more money. I'm like, "I don't
think like he's losing money because of his actions. I don't
think you really blame it on me." >> I would probably justify
doxing in that scenario, right? Yes.
>> Oh, wait. I take it back. I take it back. Actually,
Mircat Skirka is here. Yes. This is uh reviewing a debate on
Destiny doxing. Mat Skirk, do you have any reason to believe
that dashy doxing might be relevant to me or what I do online?
Maybe. >> And even death threats, right? >> Okay.
So, what you're talking about is IRL contacting somebody's boss
and actually messing with their IRL job by taking IRL action,
right? >> This is distinctively different and I don't believe
you would hold this standard for online criticism and commentary.
If I if you for example would just >> uh I think food shops
would have to admit here that like under these exact rules I
could do like anything I would do to them would be okay. Obviously
I don't believe that. Right. I don't believe that. I hope nobody
believes that. Um but that would be obviously the point she'd
be arguing here to say quite often that you didn't like me. You
didn't think I had any credibility or whatever the [__]
you got. I was a heinous individual. You really think that would
justify me being able to dox you? If I hold held those beliefs
sincerely, those are my sincerely held
>> No. No. If you me, >> okay, if you sincerely thought
I had no credibility and I was a heinous person, >> if
you were to make online commentary
and critique on that basis, do you really think I would have
that? Do do you really think I'd have the justification to dox
you? >> Yes.
If No, but but if it's to the same case that people are also
going after Destiny, right? Because the thing is is that like
Yeah. If you are you if you have an entire like network of content
creators who are going after me and you >> where's the
network,
>> dude. It's it's literally in response to things he's
doing and saying
total food shops. >> This is like >> Yes. Yeah. Total
food shops. Yes. Okay. Yes. I mean, you literally I I think you're
literally agreement, you know, order. So, yes, it technically
is. So, but the thing is >> Queenman Orbiter dickers, that's
what you are. You've been cast into the You've cast your lot
in with Quean and the So, that's why I suspected your curly hair
meant you were okay. Quean
>> I mean, you can throw >> Can food shops start
tattooing some numbers on the arms of these Queenman orbiters?
It's hard to keep track of them. I feel like we might have to.
>> I don't care. No, I >> I want to I want to challenge
that. I do. I do care. >> Yeah. Yeah. Challenge. Yeah.
Okay. All right. Okay. You see, you see what I'm saying? It seems
like a bunch of points there, but you know, me and Queen are
independent content creators. >> He's never held me to
my He's never held me to task for my Destiny coverage. Never
held me to task on my Willy M >> Um, the only thing is
we actually debated on unrelated dramas. So, he will. It's like
content creation. People like argue over takes about stuff, but
me and Quan both orbit shud. I'm not a Queen orbiter. I don't
really watch Queen that often. I didn't come out of Queenman's
come out of Chuds. >> Yeah. Yeah. But from the outside
it's all from the same group. No, like you and Queen and Spicy
part of the >> You can talk about the impression we're
talking about. I I not but I think the impression is correct
and you're playing dumb, right? Because the thing is is that
you're you're going to you've got to be the most bad faith possible
if you were to say, "Yeah, you know what? You and Queman have
no correspondence. You don't watch Queman. Quean doesn't watch
you. You guys don't get your talking points from one another.
You guys don't share data from one another." And >> more
of our more of our conversations are public than offline. >> You
guys don't talk about anything. Okay, great. I'm I'm just saying
I'm just saying that you guys all are part of the same group.
I've seen you multiple times on Disney stream at this point.
It doesn't really matter. Okay. The point is is that like going
back to doxing, right? Like the thing is is that yeah, of course,
if you >> Sorry, hold on. Food shops when she pulls up
to a debate with dickers. Okay.
Sorry, that's like one of my favorite clips. I had to go find
that real quick. Here we go. >> Let's go point by point.
Right. If if I was covering you incessantly, right? And I basically
was going like total dickers destruction. Okay. TDD, right? >> Then
yeah, absolutely. In that case, I feel like I wouldn't be mad
if you dox me. Absolutely. Right. Does that make sense? M >> well
whether we'd be annoyed about something doesn't mean doesn't
even like impact whether it be morally justified. So if you >> thought
about being annoyed >> can you one second we you said no
shouting you said no interrupting. You got very mad when moral
did that >> Yeah. Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. My bad.
My bad. >> What we're talking about? Yeah. What we're talking
about is you you voicing sincerely held beliefs and criticisms.
>> You really think that what speech and criticism on a
public platform? talk your you can respond if you don't if you
want to. If you don't want to, you can ignore it. Destiny feeds
into it. Destiny responds to it. Destiny's constantly interacting
with this KF thread, for example.
But you're saying that just voicing the criticism in of itself
would justify doxing.
>> This is an insane standard. >> No, it if that
is your interpretation of what I said, then I have no more words
for you. What is my argument? Steal me. Are you actually are
you actually >> Your argument is that if you make enough
videos eventually and your videos are like anti a person eventually
that person gains the ability to just dox you. You're just you're
making the what do you call it? You're just making the dos kid
argument. >> The saying that you're going to throw in the
towel this >> uh except hold on the dos kid was objectively
with if it's really bad criticism that doesn't hold any water
it might not do anything right. So, actually, it's not the same
as it's like if the dos kid was trying to do Destiny and failing,
you'd still have the ability to just through the intent of trying
to do him, you have the right to dox that person or go after
that person >> It's early in the debate. >> Steal
me. Steal me. Steal me and we can
>> If you can steal me, then this debate has no reason
to continue.
>> You're saying my Okay, I'm making a targeted argument
in response. >> What's my argument? Your argument is if
you are saying total destiny death,
>> the the entire chat is like trolling >> and you're
being very very harsh, >> right? And you're going over
again and again and again and covering people again and again
and again, then you deserve to be doxed. >> That's the
key term. Total Destiny death. That is the key term. Okay, >> so
if I'm not
>> that that term wasn't leaked by Chud, by the way. That
term was literally in my stream title and I said exactly what
it was for like the week after those things came out. That's
that's what it was.
>> Hold on and not say the words total destiny death. Would
that be okay? Let's get to the substance.
If Quimman were to do everything he's doing now, but he didn't
say the words total destiny death, he wouldn't deserve being
doxed.
>> No, it's not literally the words total destiny death.
It's the actions that's also associated with >> the point.
The key word >> that's apparently the key word and it's
not just the word though. The argument comes down to if you if
all of your content is purely about this person, but that's not
the case for me or Quimman.
It's never been the case for me or Quimman, like ever. Sorry,
I shouldn't say that. It was the case like in the what 3 to 4
weeks after the leaks came >> but then after that it was
like a a ton of like moving to other content. Yeah, >> you
call it right. >> And again, you're being bad faith again.
I'm I'm 100%
that you know exactly what total death destiny death means, but
you're just treating it as if like, oh, so you're saying that
he's saying this
>> Wait, hold on. Does food shops not understand that you
could just say what it means and you could just give your definition
like what that means and then you can make an actual argument?
You can't just keep saying you know what it means, right? You
know what it means. >> And if he didn't say this phrase,
>> I'm asking you to clarify. >> That's so bad faith.
That's insane. >> Well, I'm asking I'm asking you to >> I
don't think you're arguing good faith. Yeah. Okay.
>> This person is um I knew this person was dumb. I didn't
realize they were like this low IQ. It's actually like tragic
to watch. The morale debate
was worse than this. I think it might have been worse. What I'm
saying is that not only are you saying total destiny death, but
you're also doing dickers. >> I'm back. I'm back. Huge
apologies for that. Yeah, I don't know what it is. They're at
the same time every night. My internet fs for a little bit. Yeah.
Sorry. You were saying you're about to go on to say the uh the
actions that you're that you were talking about them. >> Is
it tragic?
But it's awesome. It is tragic and awesome at the same time.
Um yes, factual obviously factual. This is like so dumb. And
not don't forget it's not just the argument from Destiny and
his side is not just the content creators but anybody associated
with those content creators can now also be doxed right or whatever
any act is okay. That's the standard they've set. That's the
standard they're trying to set. I personally totally sherked
that. I will not I will not bow to that standard. I will not
follow that standard. That's insane. That's an insane way to
treat speech, right? I assume if you live in the United States
of America, you respect your own um you respect your own constitution.
There's no need for people to respect the First Amendment, but
like to try to violently hurt somebody for for their speech,
that's insane to me. That's wild. >> Sure. So, it's not
just the term total destiny death, right? >> ML total.
>> That's actually what she just Dickers was trying to
get to the point before this, right? like what is your point
you later your argument and he's like don't use TDD and she's
like but that's the key term and now he's like okay
so do you want to define what that is well it's not just or sorry
so if they didn't say TDD then it doesn't matter and then she
goes oh wait wait that actually cuts queen out never mind it's
not just that it's like the actions of that like yeah that's
what he tried to get to for
>> sure yeah okay yes I'm trying to explain yes it's also
all the actions associated with it right you incessantly cover
him non-stop you go after everything that he's associated with
even people who make his same exact opinions and and takes, right?
You make Destiny so radioactive that no one wants to collab with
them anymore because of how much criticism they get from your
community. Wait, didn't all of those people actually distance
them like on their own? What? >> No, they watched a Quuman
video and they decided not to do it. >> They all watched
me or Quuman and they were like, "Oh wow, this Destiny guy is
bad after all. I didn't just need like the pixie post or the
cherry tweet. Oh wow. Now that Jtock weighed in, I'm definitely
convinced that this Destiny guy is bad news. I'm going to cut
him off. That's what happened. and a community is tangential
to yours, right? So the thing is is that yeah, of course this
is trying to ruin his career. Of course he'll be justified in
doxing you if you're trying to ruin his career. Yes. Sorry. >> In
a video game. >> Okay. So I believe the hypothetical here
would be if somebody was if somebody was you know a decent chance
that they were a
for example would repeatedly stating that they're a give them
the right to dox you if you did content while they kept making
content kept making earning hundreds of thousands or millions
of dollars if you kept making content saying this person's a
this person's a this person's a right and generally people accept
that they are a like generally that's understood right if you
were if you were faking evidence that they were in some way.
I don't think you would actually I don't think they would gain
the right to dox you, right? It would come down to how accurate
are the arguments, how badly are they blowing it out of proportion.
It would be it would be an actual determination made on the arguments.
And I've never seen Destiny actually address arguments I make.
I see him uh misrepresent arguments I make. That's all I've ever
seen from that, right, from him. I've never seen him like go
and watch one of my cover like a piece of my coverage on the
Pixie case and or look at my conclusions on what's going to happen,
what I think is going to happen when somebody asks me and go,
"Oh, that's totally crazy." Cuz realistically, my opinions are
not that far off of anyone else's. Uh it's going to come down
to discovery. I think she'll survive summary judgment with the
Abby testimony. And I guess we'll just see what she finds in
Discovery. It'll all come down to that. That's that's literally
the opinion. And if if there is something discovery, he's guilty.
And if there's not, then I don't want him to be guilty. I don't
want him to be guilty based on no evidence, right? Well, like
I mean there's the pixie stuff, but like I don't want him to
just be guilty automatically. That's that's not what I want.
That's not what anyone wants.
>> Okay. Um >> Okay. What's your argument? >> So
again, the the same point is you're sincerely what voicing critiques
that you believe in. I >> pardon me. >> Yeah. Sorry,
I I had to ban Kathy real >> Yeah, sure. This would be
the same thing. Yes. Uh is by this logic, Trump gets to dox and
harass anybody and use any tool he can, right? any tool he has
at his disposal to to like really his media criticism, I guess,
right? >> Seal team six. >> Yeah, you can seal team
six the media by this by like I don't think that's far away from
what this argument is. No, don't free Kathy. Kathy sucks. Kathy
>> Yeah, go ahead. >> Don't
um so it' be you're sincerely voicing critiques that you believe
in, right? And you're criticizing people who would run the fence
for Destiny >> and that you deserve to be docks. Yeah,
but you guys are doing something intention here because usually
if it's going to be reciprocal or if somebody's going to do something
in return, >> this is actually just funny that it is the
exact Trump playbook, right? All the criticism of Trump is obsession.
It's like unhinged. It's crazy. These people are these people
are losing it. They've lost it. The the deranged far-left
>> Wait, hold on. If somebody's going to do something,
surely there's some kind of immoral action taking place here
that deserves to be what? Met with backlash. I like how you guys
define it as just criticism and critique. You guys like you guys
talking, right? >> Okay, fine. You you But the thing is
is that the thing is is that it's really difficult to critique
if it's just separate [__] content creators, right?
It's not just one content creator. It's not just two content
creators. It's this entire interconnected network of people that
you're playing dumb about and you're pretending to >> what?
It's this entire interconnected network of people that you're
playing dumb about. So, this is just aping Destiny's talking
points that he objectively has no evidence of, right? He basically
has to go to like you type with exclamation points. That's like
his second piece of evidence. His like primary piece of evidence
is the one guy in Spicy Chat one time. And then his secondary
piece of evidence is people type with dot dot dot or exclamation
point. They say I'm these are his pieces of evidence, right?
That there's like a coordinated campaign to take him down. does
not exist when it's literally the most public thing ever once
you accept the spicy chat role. Right. Spicy chat is to all these
content creators >> Dude, this is just embarrassing and
sad. >> Crazy. Like taking direct marching orders. This
is like But at least she's getting money from this, right? Like
>> um probably. I mean, when Desi went on our stream, she
had like 300 viewers. That's pretty big. >> Sure. So, it's
everyone trying to either coordinate or loosely watch each other.
>> Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on. I got to back it up cuz
Kilo just made a great point. Klein and
Is it the same? No, it's not quite the same. It's not quite the
same. It's not quite the same. I think Ethan deserved far less
when it started happening to him. I think Destiny objectively
deserved the coverage he got. The coverage that Destiny got was
deserved. I think Ethan was covered far too harshly to begin
with. He became unhinged eventually.
And maybe you could argue that it's the progression over time
that happens when somebody's under that kind of scrutiny. But
Ethan's under also way more scrutiny.
way more scrutiny than us, right? Or sorry, than Destiny. Destiny's
got like a 400 to 500 viewer kick streamer and like a 300 to
500 viewer YouTube streamer who occasionally cover him poorly.
Who occasionally cover not even poorly, poorly is the wrong word,
unfavorably. Like they aren't willing to show him charity most
of the time because they're familiar with him is is the reason
why, right? But you could argue that they they don't give him
charity.
That's nothing that's nothing close to what Ethan Klein got.
Not even
It's all these content creators all
>> Sure. So, it's everyone trying to either coordinate
or loosely watch each other's streams in order to get talking
points in order to adopt the this like little gay little ideology
like total destiny destruction as Jto said, right? This criticism
train that you're running on destiny isn't just about criticism.
It's also about one playing dumb about the doces that are happening.
Number two, you're making edgy jokes about the doc
and let me tell you what we talking about. So this is this is
what they do, right? They've taken like one action from me, they
apply it to everybody I talk to. They've taken one action from
Queman, they apply it to everybody that Queman talks to, right?
Like Chudlogic laughs at doc's because Quimman um kind of laughed
at like what Max said when Max said uh message received. That
wasn't even him laughing at a doc. It was laughing at an unhinged
message from Max, right? Unhinged TTS. It's like not even close
to the same thing. Uh oh. >> Wait, what is this? Uh oh.
>> Hold on. Why? Why is this clip been called JTOK? What?
What? >> Oh boy. We know this guy. He was in the early
part of my streaming career. >> I didn't do I didn't do
anything crazy. We're all good. >> When was this? >> Was
it tonight? I covered you guys. He won't like my coverage. I
I was like, "Ah, I think there could have been more there." But
>> okay, cool. I don't know. I don't know why he saw that.
Why did somebody link that? Oh, it got linked in Ice's Discord,
it looks like. Oh, cool. That must be why people came in and
watched. Sorry, I I got linked that. I just wanted to check it
out. His outfit is insane. Is he dressed as a pope or something?
I didn't even look at his outfit. Really? >> Oh, no. It's
a This is some kind of Asian Wait, is this some kind of like
Asian priest? Like a Mongol or an Usuzbck priest of some kind?
Oh, a Chinese crown. I see. I see. I see.
Okay. All right. Let's get back to my point first. You're actually
running like seven points. You are unironically trying to gish
Gallop. Okay, sure. >> So, let's go. Let's take your point.
Your first point >> playing dumb about the doctor. >> You're
playing dumb, right? You're plain dumb in this specific case
for example.
The thing is is that do you defend Okay, my question for you
specifically is that do you defend Max Striker films like comment
um or or or super chat when he made that
Queen's >> Doc playing dumb about great
>> she just trying to moralize. She doesn't have any point
here.
Message received loud and clear, sir. Like that's that's a clear
joke. And even if it wasn't a clear joke, I I don't know. Like
I would it's it's very easy. Okay, Max has done this and he's
never done any of the things he's joked about. But if he was
serious, I would disavow it. But because of the pattern of like,
oh, I am playing a character. I'm doing these these character
donations, right? I say these unhinged things. I do the character
because of that, right? Max has done this for a long time. I
got old donations from Max where he said insane on my stream,
like Streamlab stuff, I think. Um,
so if it wasn't a character, if I didn't know it was a character,
then I would disavow it, right? More strongly. Max would be banned
if he did it. No, no, no. It would be if Max had any proclivity
to do the things. If Max wasn't well known, right, with a reputation
and Max like edits for people. Max is like well known in this
community as like a person who's playing a character. Or maybe
it's not a character, but like they've never done anything crazy
like that. No, no, no. Not Max Mr. Girl. Max Striker, the editor
used to edit for morale. I don't know. Maybe he still does. Like
I think I think it's a character. I've talked to Max before.
I think I have Max I have Max on my friends list on my old account.
I don't know if I'm ever getting that back. Yeah. But it's Yeah.
So it's a play on like >> it's a play on like Mama Max's
name or something apparently. Yeah. >> Okay. And also you
be if you don't associate these with one another. Okay. Because
if you do defend it, if you do defend um Quimman on that, you
are enabling these docs essentially about
>> So by laughing at that max do and going no max that's
explicitly not what I'm saying. You're playing into doces. So
when you state your opinion, your hard opinion, this is not funny.
I do not allow this, right? This is not a joke. This is my serious
opinion. And you've stated that opinion consistently for months,
for maybe years in Queens's case, right? Where is the part where
you're enabling doxes?
Yes. Yes. When people dox these,
you guys are always like like playing footsie right under the
table. And so again, I explicitly banned people from my chat
who brought up the fact that Willie Max Willy Mack had his information
revealed. I said, "That's not funny. Don't talk about that. I
will time you up big time if you do that. If you even joke about
it, if you joke about it, [__] you. You're gone."
Okay? And I deleted stuff. I didn't I deleted stuff without even
acknowledging. I didn't say Willy Mack. Don't say stuff about
Willy Mack. I said, "You know stuff about information being released
on people. Shut the up. Don't put it in my chat." Right? Get
out of here. That's not even close to like a there's no there's
nothing to interpret, right? So, I've already done that. I'm
already having this label applied to me because apparently Queenman
giggled at a max donation one time >> while giving his
serious opinion that totally contradicts any idea that he could
be like uh dog whistling some like >> Okay, one second
again. You're talking to me. I don't know why you think that
I'm playing footsie with anything. Okay. Do you think I should
be >> dickers? Dickers as far maybe maybe >> I'm
just I'm genuinely trying to clarify what your position is here
because you've been saying stuff that's been going all over the
place. >> I do actually. Yeah, I I do. >> You think
I deserve to be
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. If Destiny What have I done
toame?
What the [__] are you talking about? >> Blame
him for doing so. I literally would not blame him for doing blame
Destiny for doxing. >> What the are you talking about?
What have I done? >> If Destiny was mad enough at you.
Yeah, I would. >> This is This is sad. If Desi was angry,
if Desi was big time angry, he can do whatever he wants. Okay,
he he angry right now. He angry right now. >> Blame him.
>> Wait, if he's mad enough, if he wasn't mad enough, that
wouldn't be a
>> It's because he's mad enough. >> This is uh this
is Desi's strongest defender right now. The incapable of conscious
thought. This is [__] up. The state the state of
DGG is dire right now. Okay, >> that justifies it. >> It's
beyond how mad he is. >> What is he mad at? What is he
mad at? What do you think my argument is? Steel at me. What?
What is my argument? >> Shut the [__] up. Steel
me. Why do I deserve to be doxed? Do you really think
>> If that's angry enough, I wouldn't blame him for doxing
you. What's my argument here? Steel at me. Steal me. Try to steal
me. Try to steal me. If he's mad at you, I wouldn't blame him
for doxing you. Can you steal me?
>> Have you lost your mind? >> Okay, I'm going to
mute you. You're not even letting me make an argument.
>> You're not making an argument. >> What? Wait,
am I am I muted on on food shop stream? Hold on. Am I muted?
>> Okay, cool. >> Yeah. So, apparently this is the
person. Let me know when you're finished talking so I can explain.
>> Getting absolutely mugged and she just I'm going to
mute you cuz you're you're not listening to me. Okay. If Destiny
is mad at you, then he gets to dox you. And what what's your
argu can you just steal my position? Can you just pretend that
I'm right somehow when I say Destiny's emotions get to dictate
what morality is? Can you just steal man that for me? >> Finish
talking and explain. All right. Whatever. I don't care. >> Wait,
hold on. Can you Can you hear me?
>> Hello. Hello. Am I muted on >> Marshmallow? You're
streaming. >> We're still >> It's so crazy how bad
faith like these >> It's so crazy, >> dude. Bad faith.
That small pee is getting bigger every time she says, "This guy's
so bad faith." Okay, that's all I'm saying. >> Faith like
these. It's actually insane.
>> Are you crying? Yeah. Like it's it's actually like it's
so
complete. Oh,
you're talking completely.
Oh no.
>> MVTT used to watch this stream. He was a mod in the
chat. Dude, it's like it's just so
>> Dude, I think these people have to these people have
to start waking up.
This is this is so much worse than it was like 3 months ago when
Destiny first made his like kind of vague arguments. I could
maybe understand like and when uh when you could look at Pixie's
team like not filing like super accurate stuff all the time like
there are things you could point to where you go like oh maybe
maybe this Destiny guy like maybe it's maybe it is blown up.
But now that they're arguing like the doxing thing this is so
blatant. It is so overt like
I Dude, I don't know. I It has to wake some people up, right?
It has to. >> Oh, yeah. They don't even know what's coming
out of their mouth half the time. If he was really mad, maybe
he could see >> I Dude, I don't know what to do.
>> Holy [__] All these people are so holy [__]
What are unhingedly harassing someone? part of a network that
goes after someone's part of a network that goes after someone's
unhinged
food that goes after someone's >> Wait, am I still doxed
here? Wait, am I still muted? >> Reasoned enough to do.
>> Wait, I thought muting was like to like get out a single
point. >> What is this? >> That is insane. >> She
just muted to like get reinforcement from her chat. Like she
just muted to have her chat go, he's really mean. He's crazy.
Why are we getting the echo? Cuz he hasn't muted food shops.
So you hear it from food shops actually saying it in Discord
and you hear it from her stream. >> You're still in Why
are you still in the call? Also >> I don't know what you're
talking about. Are you just talking to your audience right now?
What's going on here? >> I can't believe he is uned.
>> I don't know what I don't want to talk about here. >> We're
supposed to be having a conversation back and forth.
>> I mean she obviously just wants me to like end like
get rid of the call, right? Yeah. >> Are you still talking?
That just seems like the point. >> Yeah. What's up? >> I'm
going to be So, I didn't listen to any of that, I'm afraid.
>> Okay, that's great. That's just fantastic. Is there
anything else over >> Well, I thought we're having a
>> Got you. Love you, buddy. Anything else? Because you
don't you don't you don't even want to engage. Like, you don't
even want to like like me. So, you couldn't hear what I said
and you were saying that I don't want to engage. >> I've
been pretty cordial during this entire conversation. It seems
as though you just don't want to happen. >> You think I'm
going to be docy?
So yeah, of course I'm not getting >> Yeah, that is unhinged.
You need to explain why you should. >> Damn, you suck at
debating. You need to have them concede to something >> that
I deserve being docked. So I'm asking you why. >> That's
great. Okay. Well, I mean, if someone else goes after your job
or something like that when you're working like a retail line,
putting fries in the
are you really really after talking for 20 minutes? You've been
trying to look for a way to get rid of me this entire >> Really?
Really? After knowing me this entire time, you're still going
to pretend I'm dumb. >> Can we watch the moral thing next?
Yeah. The morale thing I would say I don't know if the morale
thing is worse. The morale thing is like the same thing. Like
she is not capable of like forming points. It's very very very
funny. >> I'm about you being
are you are you tangential in any way? Are you are you tangential
to these groups in any way? The answer
why you're denying this. >> Yeah. Okay. Great. I've already
said there
you are on the list of credible targets. Yeah. Of course you
are. What? That's crazy. >> Clarifying that because that
sounds [__] insane and hearing the words would be
quite interesting. But why? >> Okay, can I explain? Is
that okay? Why I think you should be doxed? And I don't blame
you. I I don't blame Destiny if he doxes you at least. >> He's
big mad. He's very mad. He's very mad at you. >> Can I
explain? Are you going to give me room for this? >> Oh,
sure. Your boy Sch maybe. But I don't think Brown's that bad
at debate. I just don't know how prepped he was going in. And
I thought he did a great job. He just he he conceds himself sometimes.
He doesn't know when he's winning sometimes. He could be winning
really badly and he'll just go like, "Okay, let's move on." Because
it's been quiet for a while. I think that was the only thing
I saw him do that seemed bad to me. He was like literally had
her pressed totally and he go whatever. Let's move on. He like
didn't realize how badly he was like rolling her in the >> What?
As if you as if I've been the one interrupting you this conversation.
Go >> Okay. Yeah, sure. So the problem here is is that
what a what a lot of anti-fans would typically do and especially
to play dumb and stuff like that, right? Is that they would love
to disassociate themselves without having any of the consequences
for themselves, right? The thing is is that when you're going
after a larger content creator, it's especially frustrating when
they couldn't go after individual content creators that are small
without like them going like, "Oh, what a you're bullying some
kind of smaller content creator." Okay. When did that ever >> When
did that ever stop Destiny?
Okay. Also, when did that ever stop Destiny? But yeah, like I
when did that happen? I've literally said this whole time if
Destiny just wants to cover what I say and refute it, I'd be
psyched for that, right? That's exactly what I want. Watch what
I say and then refute what I say.
That's it. That would be so awesome. But he doesn't do that.
He never does that. He just says this is what JTO says. I don't
Yeah, I don't. That's fine, right? Because then the only argument
I can really reasonably make is that yes, you're part of a network
of content creators that does warrant retaliation on a significant
degree. Because yes, when you do critique someone, but not >> we're
the we're the deep state. We're the destiny deep state. Okay,
the anti-destiny deep state. And he's he's trying to drain the
swamp. All right. >> Not only do you critique someone,
but you play >> trust the plan, guys. Storm's coming. He's
going to drain the swamp. He's going to show you proof eventually.
There will be proof eventually. Trust me. Fussy, you play dumb.
You pretend you're not associated with one another. >> May
I May I speak a moment? >> Let me finish. Let >> This
is the exact same argument you made earlier. This isn't just
>> Can I clarify what I was asking? >> Let me finish.
>> Just cuz you're saying the exact same thing you said
earlier. >> I've already heard this. >> That's great.
Okay. Because you refuse to listen anyway. So the thing is >> if
I if I just restate my conspiracy, then you have to concede to
me.
>> I did listen. I responded to this earlier. saw your
stuff you said when you were speaking to me earlier. I'm asking
for >> I wonder if I pulled up Can you pull up Destiny's
um what is it? The Destiny What the is this called, Kenny? It's
like his Obsidian. Destiny obsidian. Obsidian notes.
If we pull up Destiny's obsidian notes. I wonder if like if you
did it this way, right? If you're like
I wonder if you like literally pulled up like something like
this and were like, "Okay, food shops. So I want I want to walk
through this with you using Destiny's words. Okay, just imagine
I had Destiny's voice. How do we know what's true? Generally,
true things eventually reduce down to some physical phenomenon
we can observe either directly or indirectly. If you press this
button, the radio will turn on. It's something that can be immediately
verified. If you eat this food, you'll no longer be hungry. Something
that can be immediately verified. Some sort of feedback or verification
mechanism is essential for determining the difference between
true or false statements. Without the ability to discern truth
from fiction, it's possible to completely lose the ability to
figure out what is true or false, leading to two bad outcomes.
You could take steps in a direction that are contrary to your
interests, and you could begin to trust agents that are liars.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Who spreads misinformation? If we accept the prior
things as true, that communication is meant to shape the thoughts
and actions of people, and that we prefer to hear things that
are true. Why would someone spread misinformation? Someone lies
to you when they think their fiction will shape your actions
in a way more beneficial to their own agenda than if you'd known
the truth. Holy, that's cool. I think that's like totally true.
Liars are people who are simply looking to gain some sort of
advantage by shaping your thoughts and actions with a falsehood
that moves you in a way the truth simply wouldn't. Wait, did
I I skipped the first paragraph or something here? And maybe
we should actually read it. Man, I I might have to read this
whole thing. I don't know if I I don't know if I want to do it
right now, but uh hold on. Can I archive this? I want to archive
this actually before I move on. Last save May 17th. Okay. I'm
Yeah, I'm archiving that. We're going to read that after, but
I don't want it to be updated. Okay.
I don't want it to be updated anymore cuz I think you could literally
read this to food shops and get her to and and show her like
where she is up here very easily. Like you don't show me the
evidence of this happening. Show me the evidence of coordination.
Show me the evidence of anything. Right. Like the evidence you
have that there's a conspiracy against Destiny is they type with
exclamation points that they that one person said TDD in DMs
to another person where I was like, "Oh, I don't want to fight
with Willie Mack and Nick right now because TDD cuz like [__]
Destiny. I don't want to fight with other people." Destiny said
this so many times I can't even count the number of times. Don't
start a multiffront war. Don't start a multiffront war. Don't
start a multiffront war. Don't start a multifront war. Right?
Don't fight two enemies at the same time. If you're having a
fight with somebody, don't start two fights with a fight with
two enemies at the same time.
Same. It's the same concept. Me. >> Yeah. When you're going
after someone, you deserve to be. I I I can I I can't defend
a person going after someone's job. Do you understand that? I
can't defend that. I can't defend. That's >> That's an
unhinged thing to defend. >> That's That's fine. I What's
the argument for me? Cuz here's the problem. All right. And here's
why I'm asking you this is because as soon as we accept the argument,
there's a whole network of content creators that ought to be
doxed on mass. You seem to have this like vague network. Can
I Sorry. Can I I thought you weren't against
>> Can I Can I finish this? Thank you. >> So, as
soon as you justify that there's an entire network of content
creators that deserve to be doxed, you suddenly have to like
justify how deep in the network they are and how much they contribute
to this to this problem, right? But as soon as you as soon as
you try to nebulize it to an entire group of people rather than
specific people with specific actions that you can you can point
at and you can criticize,
>> I'm now somehow being roped in to say that I deserve
to being doxed when I'm asking you why do I deserve to be doxed?
>> Sure.
So if Destiny if Destiny has doxed um what's a content creator
that is not from your space
>> against Destiny? I'm eating a [__] dino
nugget. Do you even eat dino >> A content creator from
not who's not in my space. Vsauce.
>> dude. Okay, give me two seconds. I'm going to get some
water. I'll be right
>> Eating smacking lips is gross, though. >> Okay.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's just say
I was going to bring up Hassan, but even Hassan is like justifiable,
I think. Um, >> who isn't by your standards?
>> Okay. Chud, man, is Chud just That really depends. I
think right now. No, I think right now >> Destiny called
him out by name. He runs spicy chat. >> Yeah, that's great.
Yes, but the thing is he's contributed to it, right? >> He's
fed into this total Destiny >> death and it's not and it's
not justified and it's not justified to dox Willie Mac. What
are you talking about? Yeah, of course. So, for example, Willie
>> he's [__] not. What the [__]
are you talking about? I think you're playing dumb. I I really
think you're playing. >> No, I genuinely don't know how
I can be justified to be. I'm sorry
about this. Is Willy M does Willy does Willie Mac share a large
intersection of audience with Queen? >> This is very telling
only because I wonder if this is like have these people started
to absorb Destiny's thinking enough that they could be representative
of it. Okay, so right here I wonder if this is how Destiny thinks
of it. Like actually more than your actions, the association
is what picked me off, right? Because that's how his Kiwi Forms
thread operates against him. They don't care about what those
other people do as much. They do to an extent, but it's like
the the motivations of those other people is just down to the
person, right? Like each individual person who would docks. It's
just people around Destiny. And I wonder if that's what Destiny's
trying to do. Food Chop said it earlier. They're making Destiny
toxic to collaborate with, right? I wonder if that's essentially
what he's going for in the opposite direction. I don't want like
I don't want to actually do any defense. I'm not finding justifications.
It's the connection. That's all it is. The connection to these
people I dislike who I who me off. That's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to make them radioactive to everybody else cuz that
is in essence what they're trying to do, right? And I wonder
if that's not closer like if that doesn't kind of solve this
a little more a little more closely.
>> We and you as well and also participate in spicy chat
and talks in there often about TDD and his entire thing is contributed
towards like total destiny destruction or is he a target because
you guys these are new things that you're setting out. We'll
talk regularly in spicy chat and then what? So you have a big
audience crossover with Quan. You talk in spicy chat. >> I
just want to I want to thank whatever mod banned me from spicy
chat. Okay. Thank you very much. Uh apparently Destiny will no
longer be attempting to dox me now that you guys have banned
me. Okay. Cuz that is one of the major sins being participating
in spicy chat. That's a dachshund. That's a dachshund. Better
believe that's a Dachon because you're pretending. No. No. No.
No. No. No. Because you're pretending. You're pretending as if
every single person who is even minorly associated with being
anti- Destiny is doxible on my list, which is not true. And I
can't believe >> he's trying to get your criteria out of
you.
He's trying to find the criteria for you. Holy sh He's literally
saying, "Can you say what what the criteria is?" You're saying,
"I can be doc, but Willie Max can't." That makes no
sense.
Please explain. believe that you would think that. Okay. What
justifies me time and time again. What justifies me?
>> What justifies me? >> Because you are part of
the whole like TDD thing. No. When Jay Stoke says, "Yeah, my
goal is total destiny destruction." You have been on JTOK's stream
multiple time. You've been friendly with that and you haven't
pushed back against him as far as I'm concerned. Maybe >> I
don't think Destiny was or I don't think he was Dickers was on.
I think around March I was like, "Oh, I'm not really covering
the Destiny stuff as much anymore." We went to like we covered
the documents when they dropped and then it was really not that
much Destiny content, right? Pretty sure. Pretty sure it was
around March where we kind of slowed down. It was just like document
reading mostly. >> Maybe I'm wrong. Maybe you can pull
up a clip or something of you pushing back against that.
>> Now I have to push against Oh, I know what this is too.
I think it's a lot of the aerodyite coverage was um off. I think
that's what it was. Right. Dickers could have used our relevant
as an example. He could have. Yeah. >> And you make anti-desty
streams. And you make anti-destiny stream
that irrelevant lost his mind. >> Who's that? Sorry. >> Wasn't
Yeah. Yeah. That really and Supreme lost their minds. Yeah.
>> The same [__] talking points as >> I
don't believe I've actually made a Destiny stream in months.
Like nothing just came out. I'm not interested in it >> Dumb.
All right. Yeah. Okay. You're just plain dumb. >> I mean
find my content. You're saying that I justify being dogs. I mean
like prove what you're talking about. >> That's Wait. Is
there anything else? because I feel like I give up, dude. >> No,
I don't think Dickers does that much Destiny content. He's far
closer to Chud in that he um he didn't really follow Destiny
that closely before. And so when Destiny I think Dickers basically
only picked up doing Destiny content when Destiny started doxing
people he knew, right? That's when Dickers was like, "Wait, what
the is happening here?" He started calling it out, right? That's
like when he started picking up any of the Destiny content. He's
like, "Wait, what? This is insane."
Now, I think he was broadly aware of the other stuff, but I don't
think he covered it extensively. He probably covered when it
dropped. Right. >> I'm running. I I be running. I'm running.
I'm running. I'm running. Is there anything else?
>> This conversation from the start. I mean, I'm asking
what have I done? It deserves it. Right. >> Every single
time every single time I explain myself, you you just like >> because
I'm I'm saying that I don't do any of that, right? And you don't
know that I do any of that. But basically under your >> you've
you've already said dickers can be doxed before actually looking
at what he's done or being able to name anything he's done. Like
that is indicative of your mindset right off the bat >> like
immediately
under the standards that you're setting out here. I do actually
deserve to be repeat myself based on stuff that you don't know
that I've done. >> Sure you are. It is really people who
you think are vaguely associated. >> It is really hard.
It is really hard for Destiny to just simply say, "Oh, it's just
Queenman. It's just JT stuff."
>> Oh, okay. So, he did he did do coverage, but I mean,
he did the same coverage everybody was doing at that time. Like,
I'm sorry. That was the biggest that was the biggest thing going
on for content. It's not like that would be that's not crazy.
That's not weird. >> Because the thing is is that what
else >> I rejected even for Jim
as well. >> Okay. You like see you don't even let me explain.
You're like, you're like, "Oh, wait. Why? Why is the What is
the Why is the conversation over? Why Why do you no one talk
to me? Why do I deserve getting ducks?" And I tried to Oh, guys,
we are three subs away from another hour on the stream. If you
guys want to throw three subs down, we watch them debate with
food chops. We could watch pretty much anything to be honest
with you.
>> Provide justification. You just I don't know. You just
>> What I'm saying your justification is like dog like
you don't know what I'm You don't know who I am. >> You
still think that I deserve to be >> Anything else? The
problem is this entire like nebulous network of people is so
loose weave that he justifies doxing anybody who even talks against
Destiny who Destiny doesn't like. >> It's so loose. I can't
believe Yeah, that's right. I can't believe Destiny has already
doxed Willy Mack. That's so crazy, dude. I can't believe I can't
believe Destiny is the one that has I can't believe Destiny has
docked Nicholas Dioro. I can't believe Destiny has doxed Nicholas
Theory. Oh, wait. He didn't even though they were both anti-
>> What is this? It's a gifted sub from Shsky. Thank you
very much. Thank you very much, Shimsky. Let me back it up a
little bit. >> Destiny has docs Nicholas Leor. Oh, wait.
He didn't. Even though they were both anti
>> and had multiple streams and like videos that are anti-
Destiny. >> Sorry. That's crazy. >> Just to be clear.
Just be clear. What point are you making right now? >> My
point is that he clearly doesn't go after every single person
that makes a criticism or critique of him. But you're painting
it out as if that he's going after every single person who's
making a criticism or critique after him. As far I'm concerned,
the only thing Destiny has ever done is call Nicholas Dioro a
vulture. All right. A vulture. He didn't
>> No, Destiny knows if he doxes Nicholas Dioro, he is
going to die,
right? Figuratively,
>> like you can't go after a massive creator and start
doxing them. Although also Nick's name is literally Nicholas
Dioro from what I understand. one sub away for another hour in
the stream, guys. So, that's a little different. >> And
Subbox Society five gifted. That's 50 65.
That's $20 over to the next hour. Okay. I'll probably increase
the next hour, but thank you very much, guys. 25. Okay. We'll
do like this.
Okay. All right. Thank you guys very much. It's another hour
on the stream. Yeah. If Destiny went after Nicholas Dioro, I
think he would be in a lot of trouble. I think he would get totally
run over by a lot of the commentary people. Then you'd have like
Turkey Tom making videos. You'd have like that whole sphere of
people also competing
>> Tommy C. >> Tommy C would do some crazy streams.
Tommy C go wild. Tommy C go buck wild on his boys. Nicholas Dioro.
But the thing is is that yeah it seems as though Destiny does
draw a distinction between who is part of this TDD network and
who isn't. Right. Clearly Nicholas
really screaming because you keep interrupting me. Okay, that's
just great. Yeah. >> Is there anything else, >> This
this conversation has has ended like like dude,
this is
so so so
painful to watch. Holy sh I
and Destiny totally supports this person. This is like Desi's
number one guy on YouTube right now.
>> [__] five minutes ago. >> Wait, hold
on one second. The the difference here is, okay, when I started
off as a Destiny sweeper, I debate with Queenman all the time
directly on stream, offream about like whether or not this guy
was terrible, okay? I actually could throw back I I could actually
throw ideas back and forth. I could actually express my thoughts
uh that this person is no capability, it seems like. >> I've
been wait, pardon me. Just hold on for two seconds.
Uh, if food chops wants to debate on this stuff, I mean, we could
I maybe maybe she's just been throwing these debates horribly
against Willie or sorry, against morale against Dickers. Maybe
she's been throwing these debates horribly. I don't know. >> Yep.
I'm holding on. All right. >> yeah. Getting your talking
points. Yep. >> No, I've been I've been talking an audio
>> Yeah, I've been sent. Yeah, I've been sent. Yes, I know.
I know. This is You're You're doing the exact thing that you're
proving me of like like that. I'm I'm I'm trying to say, but
you're the one playing dumb about it. But okay, >> this
is Aiden. >> You're the one that is literally >> don't
really know that much about about Destiny at all to be fair.
>> Did he say Aiden doesn't know that much about Destiny
at all? Okay. Okay, dickers. You're like giving them reason to
suspect us now. Okay. >> You don't Aiden doesn't know anything
about Destiny.
Are you saying, bro? What the are you saying right now? >> There's
no way he just said that. Let me >> I'm I'm I'm trying
to say, but you're the one playing dumb about it. But okay, >> this
is Aiden. >> You're the one that is >> don't really
know that much about about Destiny at all. To be fair, >> Aiden
don't really know that much about Destiny at all. Are words that
just left Dicker's mouth? Are you serious? Dickers, is Dickers
an op? Is Dickers like a Destiny op that's supposed to make us
look bad or something. Don't just deny things that are like patently
true. Dickers, the [__] you doing? >> Aiden
doesn't know about a part of it, too. I don't care. Yeah, Aiden's
a part of it, too. I don't care. Yeah, that's >> a part
of it, too. >> Yeah, of course. What the >> is morale?
>> Aiden is always the one that's always like Aiden is
always the one that's like, "Oh, have you heard about this streamer
called Queman? He's like really good and you should debate him."
Yeah, of course. What the Of course.
>> The visceral hatred for Queenman coming out there. Um,
love to see it. >> Dude, morale pulled up a DM today and
somebody sent it to me and I don't know what the we're doing
here anymore, dude.
Dude, I don't even want to pull it up. I don't think I can pull
it up. It's from the DMs with uh it's from the DMs with that
minor that food shop was was in. Maybe I should try to get those
DMs from Aiden. We could go over them. >> Right. So, it's
because I have a good >> playing because you're you're
doing a great job.
>> Why are you interrupting? >> You're doing a great
job. >> It's because I and Aiden have like what a content
association with Queen. We're in like the same sphere. We orbit
the same people, the same logger streamers like Chud. >> Yeah.
You're you're you're in the same servers. You're in the same
like orbit. >> So that justifies us being docked cuz we're
on the same servers and we're in the same content sphere. >> Yeah,
because because because you guys the collective goal of you guys
is total Destiny destruction. Yeah, of course. >> Is it?
That's not my goal. >> Yeah, it is. It literally is. Okay,
then I guess for associating yourself. That's
>> The person I said that to, by the way, is Tread Logic,
who just doesn't do Destiny content, right? who only had his
like burning hatred, his his sea towards Destiny content broken
by Destiny literally getting like accused of crimes. That was
the only time he covered it. So like I'm saying that to somebody
who objectively doesn't participate in any way. In no way
does he participate? >> It's crazy. >> What are you
talking about? I orbit Chud. I haven't done any of this. So it's
because I have a content association with Queen. I'm in the same
service as queen. Are you really telling >> I have spoken
negatively about Destiny?
>> This is really justification for doc. You are serious
in this point. This isn't a troll. >> I keep on repeating
this but like you >> I genuinely don't believe that you
believe it. You you're saying that that is enough. I'm associating
with
the same servers and I also dislike >> the TDD shouldn't
be an argument at all. The argument should just be the points
but then you have to show then you have to show evidence. If
you want to argue that I made a point, you have to show some
evidence of it or ask me what my point is now. Right? You have
to either go to me or you have to show me evidence of what my
point was and I could justify a change or I could defend that
point. Right? That's how this works. Show me evidence that I
said the thing because I believe I've been misrepresented by
Destiny almost the entire time he's been trying to represent
my opinions. Okay? So, you have to show me evidence of the thing
I said or or
just
please for the love of God come and talk to me. Right? anything
but they they can't do that. They don't want to operate in real
>> like destiny.
>> If somebody goes after your job, do you feel as though
like >> No, answer that question. Just clarify.
>> You think it is just those three I associate with. >> So
the the return question here is are individual political streamers
who cover Donald Trump like okay they're they're totally okay
to be doxed. Maybe not even Trump, maybe not uh let's say the
CEO of a company or something, right? If there's negative coverage
going towards the CEO of a company, it's just like it's people
reporting on stuff. You don't have to like it, but you don't
get to dox those people. If they're defaming you, that's what
defamation laws, that's what like slander and defamation laws
are for, right? Liel laws. If we're defaming you, if we're if
we're lying about you, then sue us. And if we're not lying about
you, then [__] off. We're in the same servers. And
I also dislike >> Handle handle this hypothetical first.
Handle this >> Can you answer my question just real quick?
I've asked it like a couple times now. I I think I I think I've
>> So just on those three factors, I'm I'm trying to clarify
exactly what your what your parameters for are for this exactly
what the criteria like >> is it having audio issues or
or or what's going on. >> No, I can hear you. I'm just
like interrupting you cuz you're trying to like argue over me
to like pivot away from the point. >> So I'm I'm literally
just trying to >> I didn't understand this meme when it
was sent to me. Okay. I didn't understand this meme when it was
sent to me, but apparently I'm being told that this is the minor
attracted person's flag. Okay, there's a take on our logo for
our Discord. Okay,
I do love that this is where the DJers hang out, though. This
is the new DG
hub.
I I guess
dude, these people have no no sense of optics at all. Sorry.
Uh not that they're using this. They're not using this. They're
not using this, but a bunch of DJs are hanging out there and
food shops is a a small P apparently. I don't know what that
means. Very weird [__] Okay, >> like evaluate
what your parameters are for this. >> Okay, I'm in the
same service as Queen. Just hold on. Let me lay them out. >> I
just saw a funny chat. I just saw a funny chat. I I just saw
a funny chat. I thought you'll get D. >> Are you really
trying to throw this conversation this hard? You're trying to
sandbag the conversation this hard? This is insane.
So again, former mod from this channel, unfortunately, who ah
I I can't believe this guy. This is like Oh, it's just sad. You
see people who used to come around. >> Dude, is this not
like actually >> That faith. I I don't think you're this
dumb. I really don't think you're this >> You're trying
to point out a funny chat message. I'm trying to ask you on the
three factors that I laid out. Being in the same servers as point
out. Great. You you can >> having a content association
with Queenman
and also disliking Destiny. >> Can someone explain? Am
I crazy or are you guys now trying to take food shops food shops?
Seriously,
incapable of holding a freaking spoon to eat the porridge of
slop to feed her gullet. She's not just disabled. She scores
worse than any AI trained. She's constantly incapable of speaking
coherently. Listen, this is the This is the only person arguing
in favor of Destiny's ideas anywhere.
This is the only one. And until they find somebody with more
credibility, this is Destiny's representative on YouTube. This
is the representative for Destiny's ideas on YouTube. Destiny
won't debate these people, right? Destiny won't come and talk
to these people. This is the best DG can muster.
There is not a better streamer than this. There's not somebody
who can more coherently make the points than this. It took Destiny
finding a functional to have somebody argue in favor of the ideas
he's proposing. >> I am the person who deserves to be doxed
by Destiny. Yes. on those three factors
>> No, bro. Bro, Destiny doesn't even know who the you
are. You're like a who mega lol, right? I'm asking about the
moral equivalence. Obviously, >> you only got you're literally
I literally would not blame Destiny if he docks you. Yes. I literally
answered this like five. >> It's so sad that people call
Dickers a whoal. I I think Dickers is a good streamer. I watch
Dickers.
Uh I watch Dickers about as much as I watch anybody. I don't
really get a chance to watch Queening because our time slots
basically totally overlap and like usually I'm I'm falling asleep
like I'm asleep by the time Chud goes live. So Dickers is the
person in the middle of the day I watch like Dickers or Loner
Box if I'm like getting ready for a stream and I want to watch
some people some piece of content and Dickers does stuff that
I might cover. So I end up watching Dickers like three four times
a week for like hour. Yeah, I watch Dickers more than like probably
most streamers. He's a good streamer. He's good at He's good
at arguing. He's good at figuring out his points. He's like He
is a good streamer. I don't know what people like try to sh him
and say he's small. He's not going to be small for >> Five
times in a row. Do you want me to explain or do you want to just
keep me >> just on those three cuz you keep pivoting to
other stuff. Total destiny, death, whatever the [__]
>> Like like a
Yeah, of course there's justification. Of course, who cares?
You're part of this entire orbit. Yes. And I don't I can't believe
you're playing dumb. It's insane. You and Ralph and and like
>> he does not remind me of Queenman at all. There's there's
a complete separation of personalities. I would That's crazy
that you just said he reminds me of Queenman from a few years
ago. I don't think so.
There's there's a warmth here that doesn't exist. Okay. Quan's
got to listen sacrifices humanity. Okay. In some ways, he he
has a conscience. >> Have you seen his old streams? Have
you seen his old streams? >> No. We should we should see
if we could dig up like a really old Stardust stream. I'm sure
that would be funny. Holy. What happened to the 10 subs on the
bar? Uh, they were added to the previous hour of the stream.
I probably went too high with this. I went 75. I'll put it back
down to 60 or something. I went too high with this. It's going
to disincentivize people from donating again.
We'll do this. There is content here, guys. We could do more
content if we want to. We still technically have that entire
Myron Gaines and
Nick Fuentes and Andrew Tape thing as well, >> man. and
all these other like um chologic orbiters and and like all these
people you guys just like like wing each other obvious inbreeding
relationship that's what it is no you that we that some people
might call you know in a different in a different you know parlance
you might call this incessant
relationship networking with other streamers I don't know why
Destiny and now food shops apparently they like start taking
normal human behaviors and they're just like they try to come
up with like weird terms for them right? Or like they they don't
understand it at all. They're like, "These people just like hang
out in a Discord call and like talk about stuff." I was like,
"Yeah, I have people I'm kind of like friends with online sometimes
check out content." Wow.
>> I don't know what you're talking about. Morau almost
got kicked out the kicked out the house a little bit ago. That
much [__] are you talking about? >> I'm trying
to think when did we last DM? I genuinely don't even know the
last time Queen raided me. >> I generally do my own thing.
Hold on. >> Oh, did they leave? Do they want to come on
here?
>> I totally debate food shops on the Destiny doxing thing
if they wanted. But I'd probably keep it to that topic. They're
going to want to talk about other [__] If they want
to keep it to the Destiny Doxing thing, I'll talk to them right
now cuz somebody just said they might be trying to get in. 100%
down for that, dude. I mean, how could >> I think they
just joined? Hold on just real quick. Um, again, DG's number
one guy. Really quickly, DG's number one guy
girl. DG's number one girl. What is >> Is pretty adjacent.
No. Yes, it is. >> Oh, hold on. We just got to got to raid
from Quean. I assume
Quimman member known member card holding member of the Cabal,
the anti-destiny cabal with famous members such as Hassanabi,
Hassan [__] Bad Empanada, George something or other.
I forget that guy's full name. Uh, who else is in the cabal?
Oh, Denims, Rogan, all these people. Yeah, something like that.
>> Thank you for the Cabal raid. I'll look to keep the
momentum rolling forward. Okay, Cabal W.
>> Is pretty adjacent. No. Yes, it is absolutely adjacent.
Yeah, absolutely. And it's like you can I have I am more than
happy to call it um drawn child is literally child. >> Are
you attracted to Lycon? >> Yeah, I think I think I literally
admitted to this before on stream. Lycon is pretty Oh, you're
poisoning the well against food shots, man. >> Somebody
sent this. What do you want me to do? Somebody just sent it.
We just covered that dicker debate, guys. It was not long, but
it was sad.
Uh, let's see if the morale debate went any better for them.
You guys think the morale debate went any better? Oh, hold on.
Let me see. Wait. What the
No, hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I can't say. There's just something
really interesting that might be happening here. Just give me
a
There's no way that's the same person, right? Oh, it is. Oh,
that's weird.
[__] I see um I see the person from those apparently
the the purported minor from the DMs with food shops. This with
food shops. That person's in another VC right now.
Apparently, I don't know if they're still minor. >> I just
can't I can't be like, do you think it's real? >> You gonna
pull food shops in? >> Do you think it's real? Cuz like
to me it's like almost certainly just Kathy. >> I know.
>> It might be food shops. Hello. Hello.
>> How are you doing?
>> It's Kathy. I told you. I told you.
>> I told you. I told you. I [__] told you.
>> I said it was Kathy.
I told you I don't think it's the main food shops account. So
I was just like it's probably Kathy.
It's probably Kathy and it was Kathy.
Okay. How long do we have? We need um
Did I add the hour? I did add the hour. Okay. Do you guys want
to watch the morale debate? I watched the morale debate last
night. It was just um
it was pretty good. I think somebody linked it to me. So, I'm
just That's really easy. And then we don't have to start on the
Zena stuff. We can save that for tomorrow. Save all the big time
Zena news for tomorrow. Oh, did Merk Merkat Skirk rejoin the
Discord? Love this guy. Based. We got him back. We got him back.
Let's go. Hold on. Actually, possibly
Dickers might Dickers just said, "Oh, you're live to me." Leaking
DMs now, but see if he wants hop on.
Okay, I'll pull up that morale debate in the in the meantime.
Yeah, it was I watched that morale debate. I was listening to
this and I'm like, wait, there's no way this person's like this
dumb actually, right? But I that's two for two right there. That's
two for two. She's batting a thousand on these ones. What's up,
Dickers? How's it going?
>> You're just totally scrambled there. You totally roboted.
Hello. Oh, you are cutting in and out real bad. I don't know if
that's me or you. >> I think they got him. >> We
can hear each other just fine, right? >> The order. Yeah,
we should orders to dickers. It's over. >> I'll just um
I'll just bounce the I'll just bounce the region. It's usually
a regional thing when this happens. I'll just bounce the region.
Hello. Hello. >> Is this better?
>> Nope.
Nope. You're still kind of
>> Which shop's got him? Unfortunately.
>> Unlucky. Yes. You guys are just proving your point.
Dickers is literally on your stream right now. I just It's like,
>> bro, we we run the same setup. Uh, but I I literally
just took the setup and took the tags from Destiny's server when
I set it up, right? Everybody who's like on my server. They're
called Notable. It's literally the same thing. Notable. It's
like the same role. I don't know how we can describe this as
like a scheme. Imagine Caballing on Maine.
Oh, we'll see. We'll see if Dickers is good in just a second.
Who sent me this morale debate? There it is. >> Yeah, but
have you seen any receipts? >> Where else could this money?
>> Destiny is a doctor debating food shops.
Check out this morale video, guys. Go check out this morale video.
Like the video.
Watch the whole thing in a tab that's muted in the tab and not
actually on the thing. Watch the whole video. Like the video.
Give the video views. Subscribe to the channel. Okay. Boom. Boom.
Boom. Boom. Boom. Is Dickers really notable? Apparently, that's
the his defense against being doxed is he's not notable enough.
There's the morale video, guys. Okay. I'm going to hit play on
this. We can start watching this and then we'll see if Dickers
is going to hop back in or if he fixes stuff. >> Be going.
and they're they are openly explicitly anti-doxing. Whenever
anybody who doxes or anybody who's complicit in any of that uh
gets outed as doing that, they're banned from the Discord. They're
even banned from YouTube chat. Even if they're not like active
in the YouTube >> after Sure. So after the Max Striker
um
I'm not saying that >> you made a claim just you can say
not Hold on. Take that one back. Hold on. Take that one back.
Hold on. >> Hold on. >> I want I want you to really
quick. I'll let you I'll let you finish your rant without any
interruptions. I swear. But on this point specifically, I want
like a genuine concession like, "Hey, I was wrong about that."
If I am right, I just don't have a >> I've already sold
you guys on this debate. We don't need to watch that. >> Uh,
no. >> Let's go. Let's go. >> You don't know that
or you disagree? What does the no there mean? >> Oh, no.
>> Wait, what? >> Little freaks. You know that?
>> dude, this cat meow person, don't debate him. He's a
troll.
Your your chat is full of anti-content
little freaks. You know that >> the fact that anybody's
leaning on that donation message is delusional. Yes, it's obviously
delusional. I know. I
>> you don't know that or you disagree. What does the no
there mean? >> Oh, no. I No, I totally didn't know that.
What? That's crazy. >> I need to go back and grab my VOD
from uh the night like the Willy Mac stuff happened. I need to
go back and grab those VODs just so I can um prove that out.
If I don't have those VODs, I'm I feel like people are going
to get >> I don't understand. I don't understand what you're
trying what what do I want to talk about? >> I watched
your Destiny conversation yesterday a bit of it towards the end
I think or maybe in the middle. I didn't watch at the start and
it seems it it seemed like uh when he would say something or
when he would give a take you would just you wouldn't give any
push back and I wanted to I wanted to press you on that a bit
>> the the recent the recent Willymax stuff. It seems like
you're you're >> dude at some point in that conversation
I believe Keeles it's not Keles food shops says something like
they're trying to compare you to like Keffles with Kiwi Farms
and that's just insane. It's not even close. It's like wait do
you know the dimension is being compared on it's literally the
exact same and she just couldn't she couldn't fathom the comparison.
She was trying to get Kiwi Farms deplatform from the internet.
That's totally different. >> You're on the train that that
Quean and Jtock and all these people are like evil Kiwi Farms
Doxers.
>> No. What the heck? That's like the opposite of my takes.
What? >> Why didn't you push back on whatever Destiny was
saying then? >> Wait, what? Didn't she just argue that
with Dickers? >> Wait, what do you mean? What did he say
specifically? You need to give me examples. You can't just say,
"Oh, yeah. Why didn't you push back with no examples?" No. >> Okay.
Well, I don't have I don't have examples, but I don't I believe
you didn't push back at all. >> Okay. All right. You can't
just say, "Oh, yeah. I feel I feel this happened. They said thought
you were comparing Willy Mac to Keles and when y'all were complaining.
Wait, no, no, no. We are also complaining or we all are also
comparing Willy to Keles. Yes. No, that those are the same. When
you make an accusation, when you try to web somebody on to Kiwi
Farms with no evidence whatsoever, right, in an effort to like
tie that reputation badly, that is exactly what Keville did to
Destiny. That is the exact same attri misattributing your harassment
to an actor you have a vendetta against is exactly what Keville
did. It's exactly what Willie Mack is doing and it's exactly
what Destiny is doing. >> I feel this exact examples, man.
Okay. All right, dude. All right. Let me know when you got examples.
Okay. Jesus. >> So, you're just refusing to talk unless
I get you like a clip. >> I mean, do do you have any examples?
Cuz I certainly didn't think that this was an issue. So, it's
like I I don't even >> So, I think in this combo, if I'm
not mistaken,
I I got the impression that food traps didn't defend like this
defensive doxing thing. I could have sworn she didn't defend
this and she had to get other people other unhinged EGers to
come on and argue it for her. >> It's like it's like why
do I have to dig up clips where I don't believe there was an
issue for you, right? Like why
I'm talking to you right now. We don't need to even do clips.
>> Okay. I mean, that's >> on the top of my head,
Destiny D. At one point, Destiny was like, >> "Oh, well,
like he he just basically read off all of the docks and critic."
>> Uh, yeah, this is also, but we'll um we'll wait until
that comes up cuz it comes up in this debate. I listen, but just
like in the fast sarcastic voice and then you just like laughed
as like obviously implicitly.
>> Also got back to GM and back battles on uh on >> RA,
right? There's that as But it it seems like all that criticism
against Destiny is valid. Like why is Destiny suddenly anti-
Kiwi Farms when he was, you know, okay with it existing in the
past, right? >> I don't think Destiny was ever anti Kiwi
Farms generally, right? >> Does that make sense, >> bro?
He is the same person who defended Kiwi Farms hardcore. He was
fighting on the front lines against Kiwi Farm. >> You think
he's pro Kiwi Farms now? No. He's always been ambivalent about
it. >> you don't think he's anti- Kiwi Farms now? He is
anti-Quy farms only in the sense that he has an active thread
on him and he hates it. >> Why does he hate the threat?
>> Like but but >> believe he had an active thread
back then as well. No.
>> You ever thought the same way Hassan bad maybe you're
bad? >> Um yeah, I have thought about that a little bit.
>> Like the existence of Kiwi Farms, if we're talking about
the existence of Kiwi Farms, I I don't think he's ever argued
against the existence of the site itself. No, he doesn't even
he doesn't even think there's something inherently wrong about
his own thread on Kiwi Farm because Kiwi Farmers can Kiwi Farm,
>> so who cares? >> True. True. I love Kiwi Farms.
Why does he associate Kiwi Farms with people who are like against
him? >> He hasn't he hasn't said that either. >> He
hasn't associated Kiwi Farms with people who go against him like
Queen or Jtock or like Pesco. >> Wait, what the Cuz Kiwi
Farms is unhinged. Wait, but how do you how do you mean by that?
Kiwi Kiwi Farms is on. >> Um, Loki Coco, I I understand
that we should do that, but for us, uh, Destiny has blessed us
with like basically what we imbuing this person with his authority
by getting on her stream and ar and like promoting her. Destiny
is like trying to up this person, right? So, unfortunately, as
much as I know they're not serious, I know they're
u this is Destiny's guy until there's another Destiny guy that
we could that'll actually engage in any way,
that it's just like, hey, if somebody's going to defend that
this is a good idea, everybody around Destiny at least has the
shame to either pretend to try to ignore this or to go like,
yeah, I don't really agree with it, but I I'm just here for money.
Right? Like Connor just goes, "Yeah, I don't agree with it, but
I'm here for money. I'm just here for money, bro. I don't know
what you want me to say. I'm here for money. I'm going to feed
my family. Good luck." Like, at least that's what they say. They
don't try to actually defend it. This is the only person defending
it. Endorsing a lolly gun is very funny. It is kind of funny.
How is Kiwi Farms >> I mean, I took a look today and you
know there were they whatever you do search up my name. Listen,
okay, they they call me a Vietnamese cashier. All right. What
>> Yeah, that's unhinged. What?
Vietnamese >> I've never even worked in a grocery store.
Yeah, >> they're unhinged because you've never worked in
a grocery store. >> And also, they they they ask for my
dogs. It's weird. Like, what the That's >> How's that different
from any other like forum or or social media? People do that
on Twitter, >> but Kiwi Farms is like this coalesed community.
Like if you if you look at Twitter, it's like a lot bigger. It's
a lot broader, right? But if you look at Kiwi Farms, it's like
this more niche coalesed like niche space. No, like no one would
ever in good faith compare Twitter with Kiwi Farms. That's insane,
>> Yeah, Twitter is worse. >> That's a crazy comparison.
>> How's that crazy comparison? >> Okay, I can't
tell if you're being good faith or not. Like, what do you mean?
>> You can't tell. I'm asking you a >> Okay. Twitter.
Twitter is this widespaning website hosted by Elon Musk.
>> Uh-huh. So TW Twitter has a a broad purpose beyond just
doxing and Kiwi Farms doesn't really have a broad purpose beyond
just like, you know, a logging content. >> Okay. The richest
man in the world where what they do is
on the side. >> Like I'm sorry. There is an argument she
could make here, right? That Kiwi Farms has a more narrow purpose,
more narrowly tailored purpose. So you can define it as bad more
easily. >> Hey, hold on. You want me to list the [__]
differences, so I will. Okay, [__] Let me just finish
this first. Okay, so >> by the way, never considered making
that argument that like, oh, Cubarm is not that bad. It's like
comparable to Twitter. I've never considered making that argument,
but I just want to point out we can easily come up with the the
downsides of that.
>> that Dickers back. It is. What's up, Dickers? How's
it going? Join the presentation. Audio's fixed now. Yes,
I'm all fixed. Yes, it is. Let's go. >> Lovely stuff. How
is it going?
>> Oh, pretty good. >> Watch that debate. I thought
it was going to be more substantive. People told me she got destroyed
and she did, but I was like I thought you would have just actually
gotten to the points. It didn't even
>> It didn't even get there. >> It didn't even get
to that. I It didn't even get to there. No. Um I I'll be so honest.
I don't think that was a good show of debate. Um I was anticipating
a completely different conversation.
Um, I didn't anticipate it being like sidelined so quickly into
simply having association with you and Queen being the justification
for doxing somebody. That just seemed like totally bizarre to
me. It seemed like pretty quickly like 6 minutes in, >> she
was obviously just trying to like eject out of the conversation.
I think I asked a clarifying question. >> Oh, you're being
bad. I don't think anything else to say to you. It's like, oh,
okay. This is not going to be all right. She's going to have
one flat out the door the entire time then. Nice. Um, >> dude,
I love that conversation, but >> Sorry. My favorite part
by far, I think Kenny's favorite part, too, is where she was
like, >> um, like I don't blame Destiny for doing this.
He's really mad right now. And you're like, wait, what? And she's
like, what? Wait, you don't understand? Still mad my point. Still
mad my point that like Destiny's angry, so I don't blame him
for doing this. Like, what?
>> Yeah. with with the justification obviously being that
like if he wasn't mad
um she's constantly flitten you'll see this in the debate with
morale constantly flitten between what Destiny feels is the case
what optically looks a certain way and then what is a certain
way and she'll do it based on like whatever she feels is like
best for her points but yeah it's totally fractured I don't think
I've had a conversation with somebody online and come away like
feeling genuinely so like I don't know
feeling like they're such a pathetic individual. It's genuinely
bizarre. I don't know if you caught earlier, somebody sent me
a clip. She was like um I think she was having a conversation
later with with Zip Zip um some DG guy
um like asking whether she should be worried about her channel
getting taken down for telling somebody they deserve to be docked.
I mean, hopefully, you know, hopefully um well, hopefully nothing
happens. um you know obviously um but >> I I don't want
them I there is so like even if we were evil, okay, we're not.
But even if we were, I would want nothing bad to happen to them
because they are the perfect representation of everything Destiny
stands for now. Okay, they're just so I love that for them. I
love that for them. I love that for DG. I don't want them going
anywhere. >> Long live food shops. Okay, >> to be
fair, I shouldn't even do the uh I shouldn't even do the half
in halfout joke. I think somebody said in my uh chat afterwards,
they were saying like, "Oh, you know, I think there's somebody
who's justifying how other creators should be doc
like flimsy reasoning like they 100% they deserve to be docks."
Like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Went on like a 5minute spiel
about how that's just like no. There's like there's no basis
to be able to say that we're like any better if that becomes
a standard.
>> Yeah. Well, I just I basically don't report people as
a matter of like course. I just like whatever. It's all it's
all speech and like even if the speech is bad, even if it's like
really bad, I still don't usually advocate reporting. It's like
somebody either it's bad enough that people will just naturally
do it or like I don't need to point people towards it. You know
what I mean? That's kind of how I feel about it most of the time.
Also, Billy Jo, no, we're we're we're not even going to do the
joke right now cuz they've ruined the joke. Okay, I I get it.
You're doing metahumor on the max donation. Okay, I get it. It's
It could be funny, but we're not gonna go because apparently
that's advocating doxy to these people. Obviously that standard's
insane, but I'm just demonstrating right now. Okay. That we don't
we don't want that. >> Yeah. Sorry. That's that's
me up too. Yeah. Yeah. >> But it's like I'm I'm going to
adhere to their standard in the moment because obviously it's
like a heated moment. I'm not going to like raise the temperature,
but it it's an insane standard. Like we can still criticize that.
It's [__] stupid.
Obviously,
nobody on their side aderes to whatsoever. So, >> I mean,
they never would either. It's like a completely ridiculous standard.
I mean, the the only difference between like you like Queen and
me and then Willie Mac is Destiny liked Willy Mac's video. Um,
like spreading the exact same narrative narrative, saying the
exact same thing. Um, but >> well, you saw that he got
it from Destiny, right? Have you seen these >> Will Mac
100%. Yeah. when they're over the interview together and he's
spinning the exact same yarn about how Billy Mac's going to get
docked by these
>> No. Oh, sorry. The DMs. Desi leaked DMs >> Did
you see that? >> I did see that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. People
sent that to me. Oh my god, dude.
>> I leak. >> He pulls up that he sent this to Willie
in a DM and he's like, "Yeah, I sent this to Willie." And he's
like, "This is proof that like they're going after you." The
better one was the Spencer. He sent the Spencer log. And I'm
sitting here and I'm like, there's no way that without even checking,
is it possible that Willie could have gone, "Oh yeah, this is
Queenman's community because it's he got a message from spicy
chat." There's no way, right? If he ran with that, he needs to
be he needs to be done. Like he needs to have his reputation
completely destroyed. If his only evidence of Queen's community
doing this is a screenshot of a log from Spicy Chat that Destiny
sent him, he needs to have his his career needs to be in tatters
after this. Well, an interesting point on Willie Mac's research
skills. I mean, everyone's like just accepted this cuz Willy
said it and like whatever. >> The gate fumidor clip does
not include Willy wedding dress. It doesn't include the the location
where he's going to get
>> Which he's been running with constantly.
>> Well, I agree with you. I think the onestep separation
for me like I I agree with you that that's true. I agree with
you that that's bad, but to me it pales in comparison because
like obviously it's one step away from googling something to
having the address, right? Like anybody who is going to hit him
>> he's saying that during that is showing the location
where he's going to get
>> Yeah. which is how he ties in the rest of the stuff
about Queenman trying to get people to go and like with his like
wedding address or whatever the um I don't know to me to me it's
a small point it's true but especially to the point of like what
the the kind of research that Willie M does it's like
>> the way he represents himself >> especially after
seeing go on >> no no I was just saying but the way he
represents himself and like the actual research he does it's
like the discrepancy is what's so offense what's so offensive
to me right like he's like I'm the only who will go and like
actually talk to everybody in a thing. You didn't think the message
queen would be like, "Hey, did you do this?" >> Yeah. Yeah.
It's just it's just bizarre. Or like >> when Destiny was
accused of sending revenge portation. >> He messaged Destiny
and said, "Hey, did you do this?" And there was way more credible
evidence of that.
>> But he couldn't he didn't go, "Hey, can somebody find
me?" >> An allegation was made about Kelly Jean. He got
for like or really for not like um going ahead and like meshing
Kelly Jean to check in with that. >> Then he asked Kelly
video's not learned about any of this. >> Yeah. Yeah. No,
he he literally like tried to fix it in the second video and
then he went back to just not looking into anything for this
video. >> The past week has genuinely been so black pill.
It's actually insane. >> I know. Like standards that I
thought that people kind of had like obviously it's an online
space. Who the [__] cares? But at the end of it's
like a social circle with social dynamics where standards are
supposed to apply where things can kind of just be assumed to
be agreed upon. Apparently [__] not. Apparently [__]
not >> and nobody cares. >> Yeah. Nobody I and I
everybody purported to care. Like literally everybody purported
to care and everyone who represented like these is their beliefs.
to just like I think dude if Willie doesn't come out and say
no Desessie didn't send me this stuff and he has to be confronted
on this. No, Desi didn't send me this. No, I didn't run on this.
No, I have my own information here. If he doesn't come out and
say that, Nick has to Nick has to go on his stream and say this
is a travesty. This is embarrassing. That's so much worse than
what we thought before. Before we were kind of just going, it's
weird that he's paring Destiny's like talking points one to one,
right? But that would have been him hearing it and then going
and seeing something on his own, right? Like that would have
been a little different than Destiny like directly saying, "Yeah,
I DM'd Willie this and then this and then this and then Willie
makes a video." That progression is insane to me. I I don't think
there's going to be anything at this point that's going to make
Nick talk about it. Like Bob, I don't know. Will he doubling
down and making this like his career for the next six months?
Trying to argue again and again and again with no evidence, but
trying to claim again and again and again that Queen's community
doxed them. I nothing nothing's going to make Nick talk about
this. I'm like I've taken the black belt on that 100%. 100%.
>> He doesn't care about holding his friends to account.
>> I just hope Listen, I think that opens up to a bunch
of videos getting made on him and his total lack of principles.
And I I like Nick. I tried not to talk him like this whole time.
I think Nick's like I I think he's a good content creator. I
think he's really funny. But holy [__] Like this
has gone this has gone way too far now. Okay. This has gone way
too far. And he's the he's the one like he's the one who has
um something to lose. He's the one who could actually like change
this and and push back in the other direction. I don't know why.
At least even if he's not going to go after Willie, why is he
not going after Destiny for doing this? Like that's free, isn't
it? that's free to just go. Destiny is making these accusations
with no evidence and it seems really against any of his principles.
By the way, we're going to probably read this later. This is
uh the Destiny notebook, the Destiny Obsidian Notebook, combating
misinformation,
multiple things playing to the propagation of misinformation,
but it requires three basic elements. A person to spread the
misinformation, a person who received to the misinformation,
and the misinformation itself. And then he talks about like how
you evaluate truth and stuff in here. It's gonna be I feel like
he probably has like an entire guideline on how to prove that
he's full >> right here. >> I'm thinking it'll work
on DJs if I if I tell them like here's what I'm going to walk
through this. This is Destiny's notes. Okay, >> we're going
to apply it directly. I feel like it could work >> in terms
of what you were saying there about um about why Nick hasn't
gone after Destiny. I do wonder if part of it is going to be
concerns of adopting. I wonder if part of it because he has he
has made it quite clear that he's very very critical of Destiny
and that he don't think he doesn't think he'll ever be able to
like look past the other stuff or the pity stuff. So it's not
even like he's trying to hold on to it to make a content association.
I think he genuinely will not associate with Destiny. He's like
whatever people want to say about Nick. I think he's
>> No, I don't think Nick wants to do content with Destiny
at all. I'm like this is free to like criticize this guy and
just like farm him. He is like he is on a lull cow spiral that
like he's on the rakita spiral like actively right now like obsessing
with and interacting with his KF thread all the time. He is literally
on the Rakita train and why why is nobody hopping on this? It's
like free. I don't know. I we're just here >> I I genuinely
think the uh the vitrial that DG's put out probably does make
people think twice. I I I if if I had to bet if I had to bet
money, that is going to be the primary motivation for Nick staying
away from this stuff.
>> That like he just said Destiny's community is psychopathic
on the call with Sunday as well, right? Like that he didn't want
to risk going out before there was a victim out because Desty's
community will like destroy him over it. That if he was out there
and a victim recanted or something. Kino Casino isn't afraid.
And God bless PPP and Warski. Okay. God bless those those gorgeous
souls. Uh, by the way, Destiny's arguing that those guys definitely
those guys go crazy. Okay. Casino very funny. Not exactly against
like narrative forming on their own. Okay. Some of the Rakita
stuff was kind of wild to be honest with
>> Talking about how his kids were like addicted to Coke
and just like they went pretty hardcore
as
>> pretty nuts. Yeah, they they went pretty hard on that.
>> Uh, super entertaining show though. >> Yep. All
right, I'll let you get to the misinformation stuff if you want
to watch some more debate. But I'll uh I'll check in. I'll chat
to you later. All right. Have a good night. >> Yeah. Um
next cabal meeting is what? The 20th. The 19th. 19th. I think
it's at
>> Queen messages. Okay. It's the 20th now. He can't make
the 19th. >> Oh, okay. Gotcha. Gotcha. >> Yeah. Drink
up virgins. Anyway, see you. >> See you later. Bye.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Okay. We're back to the morale
debate. All right, we're back to the morale debate. >> What
is What is the difference between Destiny posting a dox on Twitter
and then someone posting a dox on Kiwi >> Well, the difference
is that Destiny is retaliatory in that sense. No, like the thing
is is that he feels like he's justified in the sense but people
will like docks on Kiwi farms because he'll
I mean, I feel like if you have people like perpetuating like
the infinite rate narrative about like someone and they want
to bring down your downfall, do you not want to do that? >> Do
you know what I mean? >> Yes. Basically, JTO Yes. Basically,
Jto says that there is a bunch of
um mentally ill woman that Destiny deliberately targets or deliberately
what JTO has ever said. >> JTO has never said that. >> Okay.
You didn't even let me finish though. Okay. >> No, because
the infinite rate machine isn't a J-ST talking point. It's a
President Sunday talking point. >> Okay. That's great.
But you know, he spreads it, so who cares? >> No. Okay.
>> Spreads it. >> The the infinite machine is a is
a hypothetical. Let's say food shops. Every single day a girl
is raped, but none of the women want to come out and it's just
one person uh you know doing the right. When is it ethical for
you to go against the woman's consent to out the fact that they're
getting to stop >> Just to be clear. Okay. Okay, the hypothetical
is about um it is about the system around Destiny as well. System
that allows it to keep happening. But yes, the it's also
the the reason the hype this exists the infinite machine exists
is to ask what will you do to stop the infinite ring machine?
Will you sacrifice one person to stop the or will you risk sacrificing
one person to stop the infinite ring machine >> rape even
though they don't want it to come out? Right. That is the justification
that President Sunday used to go against Pixie's wishes and out
the fact that she had revenge of her, right? Revenge colloquially,
I guess. Whatever. >> You You've asked me You You You asked
me You asked me a lot of questions. Okay. So, can I ask one back?
Is that okay? >> Uh, okay. Smile. >> Okay.
So, Pixie right now has a GoFundMe. All right. Where $53,000
have been raised for her. Okay. As far I'm concerned, I'm sure
that you'll agree that accountability is important. Do you remember
KEFOS and the 100K GoFundMe and how we were all laring on CEO
on that? >> Why don't we demand any receipts for Pixie?
Where are the receipts? Did I >> Do you have reasonable
suspicion that she's not using it for the leak?
>> So, why don't we demand receipts for Pixie? So, on its
face, you combine the concept of the fungeability of Mundy, which
I'm sure I'm sure food shops has no idea of, no understanding
of,
with the fact that Pixie actually hired a legal team and filed
a case and has been filing motions in that case >> and
you get the fact that you you get to the fact that she's obviously
using the money, right? It's super easy.
I don't know. So, the problem with Keles was she got 100K. She
didn't even hire a [__] lawyer. She didn't hire a
lawyer. She didn't file a case. That's the difference. That's
obviously those are the it's so easy to understand why it's way
different. But I believe Destiny encouraged her on this when
she said it last night or two nights ago was like yeah I don't
know why people don't do that. Why don't people press Pixie for
>> cash the lawyers are for free. >> Well that's
what maybe that's why Destiny argues that she's got probo lawyers.
I don't know what evidence he has of that. He just makes that
up too. He doesn't post any evidence. There's no evidence anywhere.
Dude, >> I don't know. I believe had reasonable suspicion
that she wasn't using it for what she said she was using it.
And then furthermore, no, stop talking. Come on. Let me finish.
Let me finish. You want
>> you don't have reasonable suspicion, first of all. So,
I think it's unfair to demand that. And then second of all, Destiny
on your stream yesterday said he's spending upwards of 300K on
this uh lawsuit on this legal case, right? Uh if she's only
>> Yeah. Destiny said Joan Schlump Peters is a family friend.
Wow. >> Raised 50K. acting as if she is Pexi is like this
this some sort of like Nepo baby or some sort of rich savant
that has like an absurd amount of money uh that she can use on
a legal case is is I think really naive and shortsighted. I think
if she is using money obviously a good chunk of it a good majority
of it at least is coming from the GoFundMe if not all of it.
Uh so first of all I think it's unfair to even ask for receipts
if there's no reasonable suspicion. If your suspicion is just
like, okay, well, Keles did this, uh, I don't think that's good
because Keflles and Pixie are obviously two very different people.
Um, and they the circumstances around why they wanted money are
very, very different. Uh, and then also, uh, legal cases are
expensive. I don't think she has a ton of money in her bank.
And even if she is paying for this out of pocket for whatever
reason, right? If Destiny is paying upwards of 300,000, how much
is she paying? And if she is paying out of pocket, then that
money from the GoFundMe is just replacing that. So more or less
it is just going to the legal fund, right? >> So for somebody
who has raised 50,000, you don't want to demand any kind of receipts
for that, especially not to the people who have donated. Like
it's kind of crazy to me how like oh yeah
say he was paying legal funds last night on your stream >> over
300k at this point. But the thing is
he has to pay so far. >> I mean wait has Destiny posted
his
>> What? I don't [__] know. Right.
>> How do we know that he's actually paid 300k? What if
Andrew Breler is just a deeply like close personal friend of
Destiny? He's representing him for free. >> Who's filing?
Who's not? >> I don't care if you know. I don't know. You
know anything about Florida filing? Like isn't it Isn't it the
case that if you file a lawsuit in Florida, it's like $200 or
$300, but if you pay for lawyer services, it's like a lot more,
dude. Like in terms of like she's paying for lawyers, right?
She's paying for lawyers. Lawyers are expensive.
>> This money is probably going to the legal case, right?
How do you know? >> Where where else where else could this
money be going?
>> Wait, dead Buddha? Is that true?
>> There's no way that's true. That can't possibly be true.
>> Yeah, but have you seen any receipts? >> Where
else could this money be going? >> I maybe you should ask
her. I mean, people have donated to her. No.
>> Where else could this money be going? Do you have Has
she post like any any reasonable suspicion? Has she posted that
she got like a new car or a Xbox on Twitter? Has she talked about
spending this money on anything else? Is there any sort of reasonable
suspicion? Or has she mostly stayed quiet and worked on the legal
case in private, most likely using the money she got from the
the GoFundMe? The legal case also isn't even over, right? So,
she doesn't know how much she's going to spend, how much she's
going to need, all of this, right? There there's there's so much
into this. We're like at the beginning of the legal case, more
or less. It's going to take like another year to finish, probably
2 years, who knows, right? So, demanding receipts right now,
I think, is a little unfair because people could still donate.
She could still use the money. this not all of the money is being
used. This is just like you out of nowhere demanding receipts
uh just like as a as a what aboutism like what about Keeles?
Keles did this thing so Pixie could also do it. It's like okay
I don't care about Pixie. I care about what Destiny's doing first
of all. Uh if Pixie is like scamming people out of money. Yeah,
that's bad. Sure. But you know I don't really give a Right. I
I care about what Destiny's doing. >> Okay. I just think
it's weird there's no receipts. But okay. >> Yeah. I don't
I don't give a [__] Isn't it weird? Isn't it just
kind of strange? Isn't it Isn't that I'm just asking questions,
bro. [__] >> I don't care. That's not any of
my priorities. What? What is the So, why what is Destiny's justification
for trying to dox people like Quean or Jtock? Why is that justified?
>> I don't know. Cuz they've just been spending like every
day. >> Wait, is XTO Freay Who's Xray talking to? Dude,
it's wild that Desi pulls KF up on stream today to like chat
or sorry, to read the post. It's like this guy just gets to pull
[__] on his stream. He gets to pull [__]
up on his stream and like me it's like oh well this guy used
a a clip that had half of a KF watermark in it. DG foot soldiers
watermark. Um excuse me. This guy's evil actually. There's no
reciprocity in the standard. It's just completely one-sided.
It's okay cuz he's big man. >> Or like constant streams
about like talking about, oh yeah, this is how Destiny gets its
victims. This is how it happens. This like how X and Y happens,
right? Like the I mean at that point like justified
Destiny. >> Hold on. Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on. If you perpetuate a space, if you perpetuate a space
in which you enable this kind of behavior, is it not the case
that you can make a justification for doxing? >> What behavior?
>> So, like basically, all right, so if you're like contributing
towards a space, right, especially when you're saying, "Oh, yeah,
this person is like a >> uh unfortunately, right-wing Lun,
I'd like to say that's insane, but we just watched Willie Mack
do that to Quean, didn't we? Actually, you tried to dodx me by
quote tweet by reading a quote tweet from Destiny.
You're sick. You're
>> This person is like a abuser. This person should belong
on the list or something like that. Like the thing is is that
when it comes to something like that, then yeah. I mean, in that
case, like especially when Kiwi Farms is going like, "Oh, well,
you know, if it is the case that um because it's it's very clear
to me that they're like playing footsy with Kiwi Farms. You can't
ever point out like one specific example where like because the
most frustrating thing is that you can't point out like one example.
I don't think that they're the ones that coordinating the doxing
or something like that. But it's very clear to me that like they
are okay with it. Right. I don't think they give a about whether
or not Destiny is doxed or not. Right. So if they don't give
a [__] they don't like say >> yeah and Jest
himself. There's no reason for them to care. First of all, first
of all, there's no reason for them to care. Destiny has all of
his [__] out there. He he has essentially doxed himself
first of all and they're they are openly explicitly anti-doxing.
Whenever anybody who doxes or anybody who's complicit in any
of that uh gets outed as doing that, they're banned from the
Discord. They're even banned from YouTube chat even if they're
not like active in the YouTube chat. It's like, yeah, these people
are, you know, explicitly removed from the communities. They
say, "Hey, doxing is bad. I don't agree with that. Don't do that."
Right? Whereas Destiny is saying like, "Yeah, anybody who has
a doc available, I'm going to spread it. I'm going to leak it.
Anybody like I we need to dox Queen. We need to dox Jtock. These
people are just critical of Destiny, right? >> You don't
think that there's
You don't think that there's any kind of
>> By the way, this is another um spineless way of doing
things. You don't think that like there's no way that you could
ever dox? Just state what your opinion is. Here's the criteria
for me saying you can dox somebody defensively and here's why
it applies to Queenman and Jtock. Right? That's all you got to
do. But they'll never do that. That's how these people debate.
That's how when you when you don't have the truth on your side.
It's how you have to debate things. It's how you have to talk
about things. Hey, I'm like a spineless and I don't have opinions
or or any positions. So, I'm just going to like ask questions
and then and then if you ask me if that's my position, I'll go,
well, it's kind of what Destiny thinks, right? Dude, get a life.
See you later, Kyoko. I'll be back. >> I don't think there
is any justification for doxing. Absolutely none. Because justification
for something like that when when doxing can lead to real world
harm like swatting uh like you know whatever threats uh there's
absolutely no justification. Uh as easily as someone could justify
as easily as destiny could justify doxing. Someone could justify
doxing you and swatting you because you've admitted to like being
a right. >> Then then what is your then what is your take
on the whole like queen Willie Max situation where he had like
Willie Max like docks up? >> Uh he was responding to a
Destiny tweet. He was reacting to a Destiny tweet, right? So,
I I think the fault ultimately is on Destiny, right? Um I
>> yeah, the 10,000% the faults on Destiny. Destiny responded
to the tweet amplifying it, right? I here here's how I view DOC's.
Okay, first of all, I I believe at this point, and obviously
I could be wrong. >> I don't know if I'd say it's 100%
on Destiny, but but like it's possible Destiny didn't see that
the doc's information was there either, right? It's possible.
Although he said he did, right? What did he say? He was like,
"I know I I might have [__] you up, Willie, by tweeting
your [__] but these people. I'm like on demon time
now." So maybe he is acknowledging that he saw it there.
Um,
never mind. I just I just remembered there's that there's that
clip where he's like, "I wasn't doing this to defend Willie.
I just hate bad empanada." I don't know why he said that explicitly.
Made made Willie look totally But >> wrong. Um, I don't
have the the timeline in front of me. >> You don't Okay,
hold on. Hold on. You don't think that there's something? >> I
don't have the timeline in front of me. I don't have the timeline
in front of me. Listen, listen, listen, listen, listen. Food
chops, listen. >> No, no. I I >> acknowledges his
docs. You are allowed to scrutinize it and talk about it,
>> So, first of all, Willie had acknowledged and confirmed
his docs. And also, uh, Queenman was criticizing >> a Destiny
tweet, right? He was saying, "Hey, this is hypocritical."
>> I don't necessarily think that's true if it's like It
depends on what's going on. Say after the YouTube video, you
could like acknow you'd say he's acknowledged and made it a public
thing. But maybe when it's just tweeted by a couple people and
he gets them to take it down, maybe let him, I don't know, deal
with that for a little bit. >> No, no, no. I just think
it's really crazy like to me how you say like, "Oh yeah, Queen
GTO is against Doxing." But then Quimman literally on his stream
where he lambasted Willie Mack all day. He shows Willie Mac's
like information on stream. He had it up. I don't think Quman
is stupid. All right, because maybe you think Quimman is stupid
and maybe you think Quumman is a like teenager or some [__]
but I think that Queman is relatively a smart person. Okay, what
was the tweet? >> It's not about intelligence. It's about
perception. It's literally a muted video and the docs information
is shown for like a millisecond, right? Like you have to freeze
frame to see that it like scrolls down and the bars don't move
proc correctly, right? Which I think is totally intentional by
bad panata by the way, but you like literally have to freeze
frame to see it. >> Yeah. When he had Willy Max
>> although I think maybe the maybe the name is visible
the whole time. I mean, he was just saying like, "Oh, yeah, these
people are like boxing um Willy Mack." No, hold on. I can pull
it up. Why? Why does that matter? What's your >> What?
I mean, I Hold on. Let me pull it up as well, then. >> Like,
what's the point? Like, like, tell me the point first. >> The
point? >> What is this supposed to prove? Yeah. >> So,
he replies to a Gateau Fumodor post, uh, which I believe at the
time, the Gateau Fumodor post had like multiple hundreds of thousands
of views, right? It was at like 300,000 Twitter views. Uh, and
then also this was a clip of the bad and panata video which had
upwards of like 60,000 views at the time as well. Destiny responds
to this saying anything involving this be guy or anyone that
supports him is justifiable. He is responding to a doc. He's
responding to Willy's docs saying, "Hey, if you dox people, anything
against you is justifiable." Okay, Willie has been explic to
me. Can't link it to me. Hold on. Can't link it to me. >> I
can send you a screenshot. I think it's taken down at this point,
>> I guess. Okay, so let me finish my point cuz I didn't
even Didn't food shops bring the queen example? What do you mean
what's his point? I probably
it's also I don't know if like she's like trying to say Queen's
like really smart so I don't think he would have done this accidentally.
It's like okay so you think he you think he's argued against
doxing for years. You think he he's created that he's fabricated
that position so he could dog whistle. You can't point to him
posting any other doc's information at any other time, right?
And when he takes it down, when he takes it down, when he censors
it as much as he possibly can, when he tries to amend the damage
he's done in some way, right?
Okay. Dead Buddha. Okay. Sure. Sure. Sure. When he when he tries
to amend the damage he can in some way. I don't know what that
that's proof that he's just wanting to like remain plain plausible
deniability,
right? Like every bad action is explained by the bad intent.
The bad intent is explained by every action, good or bad. Kind
of crazy. I think it's one of the fallacies in here.
All roads lead to Rome or >> And get to my point yet. So,
the thing is is that when you have Max Striker films, okay, so
he is somebody who is known to have like edgy super chats and
like chats, right? Like he's he's like a known community member
who is known to do like edgy chats, right? So you have somebody
who I I don't even know if he's been punished before for like
saying like outlandish things, but like the thing is Hold on,
hold on, hold on. Let me lead up to it. So when
we're in a dynamic conversation, let me finish
on an entire shop. Food shops, you said he I don't even know
if he's been punished for saying these things. Does he need to
be? Is there an obligation to be >> I mean, the thing is
is that it's kind of crazy to me that you don't need to be, right?
>> Yeah. Especially when they're giving >> Okay,
so she gets the that the super chat wasn't serious. No, I don't
think she does. I don't think she does. >> Super chats
of like why the not. He's literally saying, "Yeah, mission like
mission accomplished." Whatever. Is that an obvious joke? >> I
know. I know. I know it's a joke. Yes, it is an obvious joke,
but how could you obvious
blame anybody? How could you blame anybody for like >> You
think you should be punished for doing that like another way?
>> Never mind. uh totally different position from I'm guessing
somebody came on and explained to them why that was a bad point
to make or something. >> So what the this joke thing is
so ridiculous as well, right? Because because the thing is is
that yeah, maybe you should. The reason for this is because like
edgy jokes or like an edgy way of saying something in a humorous
way seems to be like a catchall for like justifying like any
kind of commentary that you give, right? Like for example, whenever
Quimman puts everything in a very smiley voice, in a very like
laughing voice or something like that, like is it not the case
that like in a way you can all just say, "Oh yeah, it's all just
jokes." Right? This is the modern Bailey of commentary. Whenever
somebody presses on you and say, "Um, oh yeah, aren't you doing
this?" You can just say, "Oh, it's just a joke." Hold on, hold
on, let me explain. So after Sure. So after the M Max striker,
um, >> this is the Men Bailey of commentary. Wait, commentary
people, it's only become that now. commentary people used to
go and like argue these points all the time. If you make a point,
you either get to be the like Schroingers's where you say, "Oh,
no, that was just me joking, but you were clearly serious." Or
you can defend that point. I would say any point Queensman's
made where he's being serious, where he's not where he's not
laughing, right? Which he wasn't laughing before the donation
came in when he's describing how he's anti-doxing, how that's
not his principle, how he doesn't want to do that. The thing
that makes him laugh is a donation that is totally counter to
what he's saying, right? completely counter in tone. He's saying,
"I do not allow this. These are not my principles. I don't believe
this. It's it's like disgusting is kind of what the subtext,
right?" And the donation comes in and goes, "Message received
loud and clear." And he's like, "That's actually not what I'm
saying. That's like the opposite of what I'm saying."
It's like a playful back and forth, but he's seriously saying
that point. And I want anybody to post evidence that that's not
what he's saying. That's not his point. It's like clearly what
his point is. And he would defend it. He does. He has defended
it obviously. So how no one is willing to talk. It is like bro
they just everybody went into echo chambers. They all
>> I'm not saying that after the micro his >> I just
thought it was hilarious that apparently Willie has been seething
about me and Queenman for months in group chats. Okay. W Augie
for leaking that that he just sees about us all the time that
Destiny's like sending me like I was like oh there's no way Willie
would see like my random comment. No. Apparently, Destiny screenshotted
my random comment about how Willie isn't sensient, how he can't,
he's not conscious, right? Destiny took a screenshot of that
and sent it directly to Willie. Destiny's literally the unhinged
like Discord skitso who's taking these screenshots and sending
them off to people. >> That's the Max Striker. >> Yeah,
because he saw it as a joke. He didn't see it as a serious call
to action. You made the claim that that this is something Quan
does like a lot, >> And it is it is it not his fault. And
is it not his fault? >> When has done this? When has made
a serious criticism, then when he's called out, he's claimed,
"Oh, well, I was just trolling." When has he done that? >> In
terms of serious criticism
or something when has Queen made a serious criticism and then
when he's called out on it or challenged on it, he he takes it
back and says, "Oh, I was just trolling. I was just joking."
Has he ever done that? >> I mean, I'm just talking about
the modern Bailey of commentary, but I mean, >> that's
Queen. >> That's what I'm saying. >> No, I'm not
making that assertion. These people don't have any actual points.
They don't have any ground to stand on. They can't make a single
moral claim
Right? No, I'm just saying, "No, I'm not making that claim. No,
I'm not claiming Queen did that." Well, you were just arguing.
You're just trying to argue it without making the claim.
You're trying to argue it without making the claim because you
know you don't have evidence. You know you can't prove it. You
know you're just totally making it up. So, you keep trying to
go, "Well, I'm not saying that, but people are saying that."
Well, like I think that's Destiny's point, but I don't know.
You made a claim. Just you can say not. Hold on. Hold on. Take
that one back. Hold on. Take that one back. Hold on. >> I
mean, probably I don't know about Queen specifically, but the
thing is is that is it is is it not the tone of his streams?
Like it's more like when people
specifically himself. >> I think it's fairly obvious when
he has a serious point, when he has a serious criticism and then
when he doesn't, right? When he's joking. I think there's a fairly
obvious uh, you know, switch in tone there. And the fact that
you don't have any examples to like counter this, you're just
saying [__] and then when you're countered on it,
you have nothing to say. >> I want I want you to really
quick. I'll let you I'll let you finish your rant without any
interruptions. I swear. But on this point specifically, I want
like a genuine concession like, "Hey, I was wrong about that.
If I am right, I just don't have a clip on me. I can't prove
it." So, as of now, it's like I I said something that was just
wrong. Can you do that? >> Sure. Yeah. So, well, I mean
concession about what specifically, I guess. >> Saying
that Quimman does like short >> I mean I mean it's funny.
It's it's it's funny to me how like you say, "Oh yeah, you have
to bring up clips or something like that." Meanwhile, you haven't
brought up an example yourself. >> I don't even know. I
don't even
give any push. I don't need a clip. I don't need a clip. I don't
want a clip.
I don't want a clip. You said this is okay chat and then you
told me literally we are talking. Can you >> literally
just tell me what gives you this feeling? >> The the reason
again the reason they want to answer this question is because
they're going to say, "Well, Destiny said it." Right? That in
their heart of hearts that's the reason they believe this, right?
Destiny said it, but they don't have any other basis. And they
know if they say why they think it, right? There's nothing else.
It's true on its face. It's tautology. It's tautologically true,
right? Because Destiny said it, but they don't want to say that
second part. There's no They just know it's true. It's so obvious,
>> Example verbal speak. Speak
right now. Then I'm just talking right now, too. >> I don't
want a clip. >> I don't require a clip. >> I'm not
ask for a clip. I don't like Why the Okay. All right. >> I
don't want a clip. Okay. When I ask you for one example, I want
you to tell me. So like, okay, well, here's a time I remember
him doing this. >> Example, for example, right? I mean,
that's the thing. No, >> dude. So many DJers,
so many DJers
took this post seriously.
They're like actually think this is like me going, "Well, I guess
we're just all doxing people now." I It's so goofy. I'm sorry.
I just I'm getting replies in my notifications from it. I'm like,
"Dude, there's no way."
Uh, I should unlike this. It's not funny. Okay, that's not funny.
That's kind of funny. That's kind of funny.
Okay, sorry. I got to We should finish this debate. >> Okay,
so you can't provide an example. >> No, it's not me. >> No,
hold on. Hold on. Here's what's going on. Food shots. Food shots.
Here's what's going on. I asked you for an official concession.
You said yes. And you don't want to do that. So now you're going
back and trying to be critical, right? You're trying to be critical
of my position. I don't want clips. I don't want clips. I don't
want to do the clip game where where we're each pulling up >> I'll
give you a position. No. M. No. I'm not going to give you a concession
if you let >> No, you're wrong. And now you're refusing
to concede. It's okay.
>> And you're accusing me about being bad faith and you're
refusing to concede. >> Hold on. Let me let me finish.
At least let me finish the Max Striker example first. Can you?
>> No. Concede. >> Concede. Bro, >> didn't
you say you're going to let me >> Yes. If you conceded,
say that you were wrong about Queen. You made you said something
that was untrue. You said something that was untrue. >> How
gay is it to just like
>> No. Sorry. When he says concede, he means concede or
provide any evidence or like say why you think it. If you can't
even say why you think it, then concede that you were just lying.
Concede that you're just making it up, right? It's obvious what
he means, >> man. Someone to concede like >> you
are a transgender lollycon. Don't talk to me about being gay
here. We're both gay. >> We're not even okay. I'm okay.
All right. I mean, >> I like moral interjections like that
are always funny to me every single time. >> If you say
so. >> Oh, what the [__] He's got a M Minecraft
video in the background. What the hell? >> I didn't know
that about you, but okay. I guess you're coming out the closet
right now. >> True. Can you concede >> about what?
Like you didn't even say anything. And why the >> You said
you said Queen will make a serious criticism and then when he
is pushed on that, he will take it back and use the excuse, oh,
I was just trolling. And then you said, I can't think of anything.
I don't even want a clip. I've never asked you for specifically.
It's when people defend Queen, right? Like the thing is, wait,
is it people defend? What if someone defended Queen? >> It's
not Queman specifically. Listen, listen. It's not Queen specifically.
It's like people who defend him who apparently
make jokes about doxing or something that somehow affects Queen.
He's supposed to be able to control the speech of these people.
>> Hold on. I just remembered. I just remembered. I just
remembered. I just >> When has anybody defended without
>> Hold on. Is it not the case that Hold on. I can actually
bring up myself actually. Um when Queman was covering me way
back in the day and then when I am like pushing back against
him and actually criticizing him for being too mean or something
like that, is it not the case that he constantly says, "Oh, it's
just a joke. It's just a joke." Like you're taking to
Isn't it like Have you considered that when they call Destiny
a [__] vampire that they probably know that he's
not actually a vampire that fuels his his life force based on
drinking [__] Have you considered that? Yeah, it's
talking.
It's literally talking. Nobody is confused when I say this guy's
a [__] vampire. What I mean, nobody's confused. That's
not a real claim. That's not the same thing. Oh my god. >> Besiding
him for being mean is being mean a serious criticism. >> Just
here. Is it not the case that on his stream he literally says,
"Oh, we're just laughing at things, guys. We just find things
funny, you know. We just find it funny. We're not laughing or
being mean a serious criticism." >> Okay. You're not serious.
Okay. >> Answer the question. Okay. No. Again, to to reiterate,
okay, your claim was that Queman will make serious No. Shut the
[__] up. Shut the [__] up. Shut the [__]
up. Shut the [__] up. Your claim, your claim, food
shops, your claim was that Queen will make serious criticisms
and then when he is pushed on those, he will back down using
the excuse. >> I will say I believe the come vampire moniker.
I think I heard it in a Discord call, but I do believe that comes
from KF. Sorry guys, that's funny though. >> It was just
a joke. >> Guy's pale as snow and he drinks come. I'm sorry.
Come vampire. It's right there as free real estate. That's my
bad. And then you said, "Okay, I actually have an example. He
was mean to me and then said it was a joke when I pushed him
on it." Is being mean a serious criticism? >> Yeah. I mean,
is it not >> being mean to someone is a serious
>> It's kind of funny. It's kind of funny to me that now
you're like >> associated with Destiny, by the way. Like
the meme in Destiny's community for so long is just be nicer.
You're the guy who wins debates because because you make people
mad, but you're actually not morally inconsistent. You're just
not being nice. You're being mean. Be nicer. Apparently, this
is a criticism now. You're not being nice enough. >> Like
pivoting, right? Because before I literally told you I'm on point.
You're the only one that's tried to pivot. You're the only one
that's tried to pivot. I'm kind of trying to push back on things
that you No, you're moving the goal post. You're moving the goal
post.
for any example. And I know that is being mean to serious criticism.
Is being mean to someone serious critique. You literally said,
you literally >> This is what I'm saying, by the way, is
like this person's actually, this person versus Willie Mac IQ
test.
I'd donate
to both IQ test one-on-one. Willie Mac versus Foot Chops. Who
you got? Who you
>> Who you got? >> Willy. Easy. >> Food Chops
is Asian, but there's a decent shot that they're like an Asian
with Down syndrome, so that's a huge IQ penalty. Give me an example
where uh Quimman responds seriously to something and doesn't
just like handwave it away with like oh just saying it's a joke
or something. Is that not like a serious critique that he's just
handwaved that I gave you an example of? What do I have to build
up how you
don't even know what you're saying? You don't even your claim
again for the third time. >> What are you eating? >> Your
claim was that Queen will make a serious criticism. This is something
Quean will do. Quean will say a serious criticism. Okay. Quan
will say a serious criticism and then he will be pushed on that.
I hope you're joking. No, I'm not. But I cannot reveal my evidence.
Okay, we need we need a genetic test on food shops. I believe
there's a there's a triplicate pair. Okay. At chromosome 21.
I I need the DNA evidence. Okay. I need I need a uh what do you
call it? Like a DNA test. I need to see do we have a pair or
a triplet? A triplicate. Triple. A triplet. A triplet at chromosome
21. Okay. cuz I I I'm a tricome believer.
>> And then when someone pushes on him, he will respond
back
and say, "Oh, I was just joking. I wasn't being serious." You
can hold on. You can laugh at it. You can laugh at it back then.
>> It's 24 chromosomes. No, you have 23 pairs of chromosomes.
It's a triplicate at the 21st chromosome. Why call try show me
21, >> right? Obviously, it's a gay ass complaint, right?
But back then, the thing is is that like, yeah, it is actually
a serious criticism. And honestly, this is where we're at now,
>> Clean being mean is a serious criticism. No, hold on.
Food shops. Food shops. No, no, no.
He didn't take it seriously. Like
take it seriously because Maxer makes an edgy joke and now he's
in trouble. So >> food shops.
>> Isman being mean to someone. Quan doing a serious criticism.
>> Is Yeah, of course. What the? Now you
>> Now you've moved the goalpost. No, it's what he said
the first time. It's what he's been saying since you said this
person insulted me and then they said it was a joke and they
they avoided my serious criticism.
No, they didn't. They said it's not me saying like when I call
you when I say you have Down syndrome, I'm not actually I just
said I was serious about it. I should pick a better example.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um that one is kind of a joke. I'm kind of doing it,
but I'm also not doing it. I leaned into it as a joke. >> This
is what is myself here. play
>> A critique is that you're making a complaint about someone.
>> And if someone's being mean, how is that how is that
a complaint? >> Oh, by the way, guys, we ran out of
>> Seven subs, seven subs would get us there for the extra
hour to finish this debate. But, uh, if you guys got money, if
you guys got want to donate, go ahead. If you don't, I'm I think
I'm just going to finish it anyway. So, >> as you don't
need to specifically define, like I'm pretty sure you don't need
to specifically define what the people know. Like you're >> No.
Yes, you do. Because you're saying being mean to someone is a
critique when it's not. Being mean is being mean. It's not criticism.
>> What? Okay. So, when I >> If I call you a Is that
a critique? If I say that you're like, is that a critique of
you? No, it's just claim
claim, right? Or at least that's a tough one cuz that's like
actually a thing. It's not really, man. It's It's such an easy
line, but if you try to get pedantic about it, you could probably
lock it down, right? >> That is very different from a pointed
criticism. He's being too mean. That's not a critique. Hold on.
If my friend was being too mean to me and I tell him that he's
being too mean, is that not a >> That is you critiquing
them. Quean being mean to someone else is not Quean critiquing
someone else. That is the claim that you made. >> No, I'm
I'm specific. That's so clear. It's crystal clear right there.
People said Mora sucks at debate. No, he doesn't suck at debate.
That's a crystal clear response to explain what's going on, why
she doesn't understand what's happening. And she says no concept,
right?
Like Ralph did really well in this debate. I think he highlights
perfectly why food chops >> perfectly. No, I'm specifically
talking about someone making a critique at Queenman. You're not
even keeping up with the conversation. >> I understand
what you're saying. Your claim again for the fourth time now
will make a serious claim against someone and then when he's
pushed back on about that claim, he will retract and say it's
a joke. When has he done that? >> When has he done that
ever? Name one time. I don't need a clip. I don't even need a
clip. Name one.
>> You're literally missing my point
>> Name one time. Just name one. Someone
>> No, the entire time I've been saying someone else making
a critique towards >> Wait, hold on. Did Merkats Kirk leave?
Hold on. I was about to ban this guy from the Discord if he didn't
leave. Okay, I just realized that he only joined because Lav
was back. That Lav got him banned and he immediately rejoined.
No, >> I was about to I was about to time him out like
instantly. You guys have no >> Making a critique towards
someone else. >> You were making You're literally pivoting.
You're literally pivoting. >> Pivoting hell? the entire
time I've been >> you're changing you're changing your
>> All right. >> Change the goal post. Whatever.
Go ahead. Max Striker. Go ahead. You're like a [__]
like stupid [__] that you know is not consistent.
Whatever. Maxer, go ahead. >> Yeah. No. No. I mean I mean
you won't you won't even let me finish. So why why should I like
every single time I begin to talk you just like start interrupting
shouting. So it's like whatever. >> Okay. Well that's not
every single time. I obviously won't let you talk. Are you going
to [__] talk or >> Yeah. Exactly. When he says
when I said you're being mean. Being mean implies that you are
the tone is what's upsetting you, right? You can criticize their
tone, but it's like they're not loving a serious critique. Their
tone is upsetting you. So, you could critique them back for the
tone being mean, but it's not they're not delivering a critique
or you're not you're not specifying what the critique is or why
it would be bad, right? You're not like you're not commenting
on it. You're commenting on tone.
>> Holy Max Striker, go. >> Okay. Okay. Let me finish.
So Max, >> see that's that's the only downside I see from
Moral when he debates is he'll move on when he has somebody like
when he has his knee on somebody's neck, he'll just move on.
But like actually right here he's totally correct. All he has
to do is keep kneeling and make them like figure make them come
to terms with the fact that they're I think that's the only
the only critique I had here was just yeah keep kneeling >> striker.
Okay. So my critique is that the modern Bailey of commentary
is when oh you're critiquing someone when you're making a critique
towards someone like being mean or being too edgy. It seems as
though they will say something like oh well I'm just I'm just
I'm just being funny. I'm just being funny. All right. But then
when they need to attack they are actually making complaints.
They are actually making principal positions. So what it comes
like to me uh comes off to me is that since Queman
>> so you so she is saying that when Quimman delivers a
critique he then says he's joking. Malo says that doesn't happen.
She goes no I'm the one delivering the critique but when Queman
but when I deliver the critique he says he's joking but he was
making a serious claim. She it totally misses right that she's
saying the same thing and she thinks she's correcting morale
but she's not. She's all right. Since Quman doesn't really care
about being edgy or whatever. Max Striker making an edgy super
chat saying, "Oh yeah, I got it, Quan. I got it, Quan. As a Simon
understood, yes, I acknowledge it's an edgy joke." Yes, but it
seems like because he doesn't acknowledge like this whole critique
of him being too edgy or his audience being too edgy, right?
In trouble in the first place,
>> Is it bad to be too edgy?
I mean, maybe when people can tell whether or not you're joking,
maybe it does not part of the joke sometimes. >> She literally
Well, one, she literally said that she could easily tell
>> I mean, then
I I can understand where you're coming from. I can understand
the the baseline of where you're coming from, right? But when
someone is literally called Max Striker Films and everything
they super chat, everything they tweet is like a a exaggerated
joke. I I I don't think And they're like an in community meme.
I just don't think >> like this is a strong point. >> Hold
on. Is Will Yeah, but is Willie Mack and Disney supposed to know
who Max Striker Films is? >> Yeah, they should probably
do research and look into something if they're going to critique
it, right? >> What? Okay, so >> specifically has
an issue with research. He does poor research consistently. unreasonable.
That's actually so unreasonable. And you know that is that's
crazy. >> It's unreasonable to critique a super chat to
begin with. You can't control your audience. You can't control
who super chats you. >> Okay. Like for example, I don't
even know all the members of your audience. And you don't know
mine either. I wouldn't hold you to that same standard.
>> And I wouldn't hold someone to the standard that they
got super chatted by someone called Max Striker. That's a
>> If you got Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Food shops.
Food shops. Let me give you a hypothetical. Let's say food shops.
Let's say you got donated by Loi Loi 1488 or some [__]
right? Do you think it would be a fair response for someone to
say like, "Dude, look who donated to food shops. This is crazy.
Look at this. This is insane." You think that's a fair like critique
against you? >> Hell no. But like is Max
like a Wait, hold on. Let me finish. Let me I answer your question.
Let me finish. >> So is Max Striker films a eco example
to Lier
Striker 69? Is that the eco example? Max Striker films. >> I
think so. >> Explain to me >> because both of them
are like inflammatory. Both of them are inflammatory. That's
the point of their >> How the name isn't even close to
being edgy to Wall-E Striker 69. That's >> Have you seen
their like Twitter account? Have you seen their like YouTube
account? Like what what do you mean? Yes, it is inflammatory.
>> I don't think Max is I think I think Max's name on Twitter
is more inflammatory. Federal, but >> Oh, yeah. >> They
literally LAR lightning bolts in their room. That's the joke.
That's the >> is laring as Uh-huh. Yeah. Okay. It's it's
there is contention on whether it's LAR or not. That is true.
I you know, deep down there's probably something there. I agree
with that. But yes, it is a it is it is Mammo is Mama Max's name.
The Twitter account is like larping is enough. It's like yeah,
it is obviously a joke. It is obviously satire. You can you can
argue say like, "Oh, I don't think it's funny." But yeah, obviously
it is a joke. Like obviously it is satire what he's doing, right?
>> Okay, that's great. I'm just saying from the outside
perspective looks like like Queen's doing hint hint wink wink
kind of. So >> it absolutely does not. You have to be absolutely
insanely
to ever believe >> That's crazy. >> If you literally
if you get if you get donated something that's
K, if you get donated something that's funny, are you just like
not allowed to respond? Even if it's like of like a like we got
to we got to [__] we got to drop this guy off the
Empire State Building. Like no, obviously not. It's a joke. Nobody's
doing call to actions. Queen actively says like, "Hey, don't
go to this person's chat. Don't do this. Don't do that. Don't
harass people. Don't target >> No. What are you talking
about? It it's really hard to tell whether >> but the average
person is not having this much issue trying to figure out if
this is like satire or not. >> Well, I can't tell if you
guys are being a because the thing is that I can't believe you
guys don't know how other people view it from the outside. Especially
when says like, "Oh, Joshua Moon wins. Oh, Kiwi Farms is always
right." Like the thing is that it's very clear he appeals to
the Kiwi Farms. >> Okay, let's let's switch to that cuz
I don't think we're going to get anywhere. I don't think we're
going to get anywhere on the next striker fight. Let's switch
to that. He liter He literally praises Kiwi Farms all the time.
Let's switch to that. Let's switch to that. Sure, let's switch
to that. Sure, let's switch to that. >> No, but it's all
part of one argument. You can't just ignore like that part and
>> Queman in my chat just said I don't say KF is always
right. That's not true. >> Okay. I mean, he can say that,
but I remember hearing that. So, you know, you remember that
we're not >> I Okay, he can say that, but I remember differently.
Okay, then find the clip of him saying differently. It's like
this is another strategy. Unfortunately, unfortunately, it's
another strategy. Okay? It's uh they'll say, "You said this,"
and you'll say, "Okay, um that's not my opinion. Do you have
a clip of me saying that?" And they won't have anything else
to say, right? So, they they'll have nothing else to say. You
say, "Get me a clip." They don't have the clip. And then it's
like, "Okay, do you want to debate my actual position?" "No,
you were bad faith before." It's like, "Okay, I So, you can just
do whatever you want." >> Well, yeah. I mean, that's an
>> Let's switch. Let's switch to the Let's switch to the
Queen and KF [__] Let's switch to the Queen and KF
[__] Let's switch to that. We're not going to agree
on the Max Striker thing. Let's just leave that in the where
we can keep arguing about why I don't think we're going to find
middle ground. Let's switch to the Kiwi Farm [__]
Is that
>> Wait, why should I? What the conc
don't know how badly they got in the previous argument and they're
yelling concede now. Very shameful. Very embarrassing. incapable
of understanding
This
I figured like the fact that Destiny went on their stream, they
might be like a smart person, but they're not. They're like a
totally I don't know. I figured he wouldn't just hop on a random
stream, but he he did. I
>> mean, concede.
>> I Well, I asked you to concede because you admitted
that you were in the wrong. Okay. This is not the same. Let's
switch to the KF shed. Uh, how is even if Quimman agreed completely
with KF or liked Josh Shmoon or or was a fan of Josh Moon, which
I don't even know and he seems to deny in my chat. Let's just
say that that's true for the sake of argument, right? Uh, how
is that like complicit in doxing or like a dog whistle that people
should go on KF and start doxing people? >> Well, Kiwi
Farms likes doxing. So, if you like signal to Kiwi Farms and
then you have someone making that joke, like don't you think
someone from the outside will just simply go like, "Oh, wow.
Well, I guess like Creman is doing Hay and Wingwig and it isn't
just an edgy joke. Like if Max Triker Films did that in my chat
obviously like it might be a little bit like like more of a joke
just mainly because I don't glorify Kiwi Farms like that. No,
>> sure. Can I ask a question? >> Sure. Go ahead.
>> Uh why does >> I What's your answer to that? What
the
>> I I thought you were I thought you were It was rhetorical.
Can you repeat it? >> Okay. So, if we're accepting the
premise that Quimman does appeal to people from Kiwi Farms and
he does in fact say >> I don't think he appeals from people.
Let me finish. Okay, so if that is the >> hold on. If that
is the case and then someone from the outside sees like Que and
like Max Stucker Films donating like, oh yeah, implying that
they're about to dox or do something to Willie Mac, right? Is
it not the like correct inference to connect these two together
and say, "Yeah, I I'm not sure
>> No, you could only make that call. You could only say
that if it's as clipped up, like as chopped up as what Willie
put in his video, right? If you listen to the full thing and
you hear his tone while he is saying how this is not his principle
while he clearly elucidates that he's talking about Destiny's
standard being insane. If you could possibly think that when
he delineates okay he makes a strong delineation between his
principles and Destiny's
there's no way you can possibly think when he laughs at that
dono that he's going oh actually I don't believe this at all.
It would be stupid. It doesn't make any sense. There's no streamer
who' be taken seriously who does that >> if it's a joke
or not. And for Willie Mack, who's literally been doxed, for
him to go, "Oh, this might be an actual threat or something."
>> Uh, if I were to concede it like first glance, sure.
But again, these people uh have an abundance of time. They pay
researchers. They pay writers. They can afford to look into this
stuff and figure out that it is indeed a joke and this is not
true. >> I don't think you had to concede that at all.
Yeah, I don't think you concede that at all. But >> and
yeah, Willie Mack should have looked into this and and should
have understood that this is not true. Willie Mack in his video
that he put out has a ton of issues. He blatantly lies and smears
both Queeman and Jtock multiple times. >> I don't I don't
I don't like that Willie Mack did that and I criticiz I agree.
But he has an issue with re research. So >> hey, what do
you think the odds are if you were to go watch Food Shop's video?
What do you think the odds are that she criticized Willy Mack?
When Willie Mac smears and his lies are the exact smears and
lies that Destiny himself does.
What do we think? I got a I got 50 bucks saying there's no criticism
for any of the smearing that happens. Any of like the liel, right?
Any of the I guess it wouldn't be liel defamation.
Just having no proof. I don't know exactly baseless claims. Any
of the baseless claims, baseless smears. This criticism that
you have, sure, even if I agree with it, which I don't completely,
he should have looked into it. He should have understood that
this was a joke, that this was not a serious [__]
>> She's a T. I don't know what this means. She used a
TTS for it. I watched their coverage. They gave zero push back.
Okay. Yeah. I was just like there's no way cuz Willy's baseless
like claims, his slander is just the same Essie's been saying.
So I don't understand where the criticism would come in. You'd
just be criticizing Destiny. >> Uh like, hey, go to KF
and go >> Yeah. No, I'm saying I don't I don't think she
ever ever ever
criticized it. I don't think so. >> Can dox and and do
whatever right now. Can I ask my question? >> Yeah, but
then but yeah, but then this is just where we disagree and it's
like we can't move past this. Okay, we disagree. I'm going to
ask my question. I'm going to ask my question then. Okay. >> It's
unreasonable to look into Max Strucker films specifically as
a >> I'm going to ask my question. Okay. >> Why does
Destiny get a pass uh for his support with KF during the KEF?
Uh but somehow Queen doesn't get that when he says like Josh
Moon is based or >> I'm sorry. Did Destiny receive a donation
saying assignment received? I got you. I'm going after Keeles.
>> Bro, we could totally f I I'm not going to. But who's
who's actually fooled themselves into thinking that Destiny wouldn't
have received donations like this?
Really?
>> why does Destiny get a pass with his support for Kiwi
Farms during the Keful, but Queman doesn't when he says Josh
Moon is based. >> Although to be fair, the other thing
is is Destiny just says a lot of the unhinged things himself,
right? Like he doesn't dog whistle. He just says them himself.
So, I don't know >> because Destiny haven't said
>> DG chat definitely memes about me 100%. >> Josh
Moon is based. Hello. >> He talked to Josh Moon on a Turkey
Tom stream and with him and he likes him, >> Yeah. So,
what the [__] He's not trying to make a preemptive.
>> Why does Destiny get a pass with his support for Kiwi
Farms during the Keful? But but Quimman doesn't when he says
Josh Moon is based. You think saying Josh Moon is base is the
same as having a cordial conversation with someone? >> Yeah,
I think the cordial conversation probably implies more support.
>> That's not equal whatsoever. No, >> hold on. Really,
what this what this elucidates for us, what this makes clear
is the fact that you can like parts of Kiwi Farms and hate parts
of Kiwi Farms. You can like that it's a bastion of free speech.
You can like that it is as low on censorship as you can be while
maintaining the laws, right? You can like those aspects and also
hate the things that those positive attributes are used in service
of. Doxing, harassment, right?
You can like and dislike parts of Kiwi Farms. You don't have
to say it's all evil. You'd say there's good and bad, and I think
the bad outweighs the good, but ultimately I don't think it should
be taken down, right? I think that's the the position of basically
everybody. But the problem is that the problem is that me and
Quimman have basically the same position that Destiny had with
the Kevils manifesto. While it is like that they do these bad
things, that they keep docues up, that they allow like a lot
of behavior that we see as really socially negative, right? While
that is all bad, it it unfortunately our principles lead us to,
hey, well, it's bad, but it's not illegal and I don't believe
this should be deplatformed from the internet, right? But we're
not allowed to have that position. Us having that position and
saying that like KF is a source for pime uh for archives of primary
source material, right? We're not allowed to say that without
people going, "Oh, yeah, they love Kiwi Farms."
What? Well, they've used clips from Kiwi Farms. I don't know.
Um, I don't even know that I think like talk is that bad, right?
I don't think's that bad on there either. Like, if it's just
talking, uh, there's like unhinged posts and some I'm sure some
of the unhinged posts could be funny,
right? It's funny to watch unhinged. Dude, somebody sent me a
post from someone. Oh, never mind. Never mind. And I'm not even
going to describe it cuz it's just but like some some things
could be funny. Um obviously I don't like the fact that Doc's
information gets maintained up there. It's like that's bad. That's
obviously bad. I don't know. It's obviously bad. I >> I
I agree. I know. I agree. It's not equal. I think the cordial
conversation live streamed is probably more endorsement than
saying it this >> saying that saying no wrong. I disagree.
I think >> I'm going to ask my question again. You you
keep pivoting and you keep avoiding it. Why does Destiny get
a pass with his support for Kiwi Farms during the KEF but Queen
doesn't now? >> Hold on. Hold on. If Destiny had a cordial
conversation with Techone, does that mean that he endorses everything
that Tech does and that Tech with him is like he's trying to
appeal to Tech's >> Let's use Arodite as an example. >> Not
necessarily, right? Obviously, not necessarily. Obviously, context
matters. >> Okay. Are you going to Are you >> Yeah.
No, it doesn't. >> Okay. Let's use Let's use Paradite.
Yeah. I think it means one of two things. Either one, you're
you're fine, perfectly fine with what they're alleged of, or
two, uh, you just like didn't look into it at all, right? Which
I don't think is the case with either Destiny or Quean, right?
I don't even know if Quman endorses Kiwi Farms or or or null.
I'm going off of what you say for the sake of argument, right?
So, I'm I'm going to ask my question again. Don't pivot. I want
you to engage with this question. Don't do what aboutisms. I
really want you to try to engage with this. Okay? >> Why
does Destiny get a pass? Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Why does Destiny get a pass with a support? Hold on, hold on,
hold on. Why does Destiny get a pass with a support for Kiwi
Farms, including offering to fund them, bankroll them, and Quean
doesn't now? What is the difference there to you? >> Bank
them. >> Yes, he offered to fund them. Destiny offered
to fund Kiwi farms against >> What specifically? >> Against
Keels.
>> Engage with the question I just gave you. Engage with
that. >> I'm going to have to ask for I'm going to have
to actually ask for evidence on that. I can't just accept that
premise. I'm sorry. And like, dude, did you you didn't watch
this at all? Even if it's even if it's true, right? Isn't his
main contention against
>> He did offer to fund them. He offered he said he floated
the idea of funding them. I don't know if he did. I don't know if
he even donated, but he absolutely floated the idea like I I'm
contemplating just funding their entire lawsuit or some [__]
like this, right? Was like the kind of he was saying that like
I should donate and help them out. I don't know if he actually
donated that somebody else would have to say the question, please.
Like isn't isn't isn't the whole context. Why does he got a pass?
Cuz his entire engagement is with Keeles, not like specifically
with like [__] with trying not trying to appeal on
his own [__] time in a vacuum, right?
Wait, does does this person think that as Keles's like as an
enemy of Keles, somebody Keeles was going after, that Destiny
wouldn't have been watched by people from the Keles thread, that
there wouldn't have been any crossover in ideas there? No crosspollination.
>> Uh, so >> Beards Nucas clips of both. I don't
I don't even need the clips. I know they exist. I could Yeah,
I'd probably go to Ryan Beardsuke to find the clips. >> I
have a post from 3 years ago. Destiny offers to fund kiwi farms
on stream despite Keffles is on the Vos Reddit. To be clear,
he didn't follow through. He did not give them any money. He
just said that he would. >> Yeah, there you go. >> This
page does not exist. >> You need a screenshot of it? >> Sure.
Why saying Destiny follow through the SP? >> I don't know
why it's saying it doesn't exist for you. It exists for me. >> When
Destiny told his fans to flood the Anna thread to get it out
of their systems. Yeah. Hey link to Keville start as well, right?
Like none of the standards he has apply to him in any way.
To be fair, he is in essence at this point just saying I have
no principles. I'm going to anybody I hate. Right. That's all
he's doing. It it seems like he's spent an entire career building
up a set of principles, ways to to critique like grifters, people
who don't have sincere beliefs, people who are lying. He's built
an entire career building up tools to identify these people and
to critique them. And now he is using those tools to critique
and his his study of those people to become them, right? Like
he is actually just like objectively trying to carry out and
use all of the things he criticized, right? The webbing from
Bosch, the simulacum from Bosch when he like won't watch clips.
Oh, we watched the Quean thing today. I didn't watch that on
stream. We might we might go back and watch some of that to see
how he argues, right? I'd like to see it cuz apparently
he covered the whole thing. Now, I would love to see the arguments
he makes cuz that would be very interesting to me. I don't want
to watch the whole thing on stream here today. Maybe I might
watch it off stream. We'll see what happens. He leaked his DMs
with Willie. Well, we pulled that up. We pulled up the parts
where he says he DM'd Willie. I don't remember if he actually
showed DMs with Willie, like him sending stuff to Willie. Uh,
the other thing we got though, or the other thing I was sent
today was his DMs with a guy who's a known Kiwi farmer who he
shares DMs with, right? And who was saying like, "Was he suggesting
dox targets to destiny?" Hold on, let me let me pull this up
because I don't quite remember. This So incel guy. I thought
you would start doxing people again tonight. You edged me. If
you ever decide to get scorch go scorched earth again, keep in
mind that Mr. Girls docs has been public for a while. Was this
guy banned after this or does he just allow the people who encourage
doxing to sit in his community?
Then he goes, "Oh, you should like totally amplify Mr. Girls
docs." Sock them in is a food shops mod. Like,
dude, these people are so crazy.
It's just nuts, right?
It's nuts.
This guy's DMing him directly
and apparently sending more DMs is apparently not blocked at
this point. I don't know if you care, but Kelly explicitly mentioned
Lena's LCA Farms thread on Juice Doctor's stream. To be fair
to them, I don't think that her docs is on there, but Juice Doctor
is calling you a skitso for thinking that Kelly mentions gossip
forums in those alt discords, even though she literally does
it publicly. Um, okay. I think I would just say evidence here.
I don't think it's insane that Kelly would do this, but I think
Kelly I I'm well aware that Kelly would be told not to do this
on my stream.
Obviously, talk is all over the threat of mods for food shops.
Yeah. So, like it's basically just obvious at this point that
they're like, "We don't have any principles. We just want to
[__] kill people, right?" Like, that's it. He posts
under his own name, and I believe he leaked these DMs in the
thread under his own name. Yeah. Yeah. It's uh it is a thing.
Can I DM you that? I will DM you that. Hold on. Mal asked me
for a clip. Hold on. I should just hit play on the debate again
real quick. Wait, what? The sock inel guy. Lol. That guy is actively
dodging me for a debate. I had no idea there was all this lore
around him. Yeah, these people don't have principles. Kingler,
I don't know how to tell you that. I don't know how many I don't
think I don't think I'll reach you anymore. Okay, you're just
bearing witness. Okay, I'm not going to try to reach you anymore.
You're just bearing witness. You're bearing witness.
>> So, again, I I really want you to try to engage with
us. What is the difference here? If one of these people is obviously
offering more support, more overt support, saying I will literally
give them money, right? Okay. Destiny is saying, "I will give
these people money to support their right to exist." How is that
somehow worse than Quean for some reason? I again, I've not seen
this. I'm just going off of what you said. I'm I'm giving you
the benefit of the doubt, saying it's true. How is that somehow
uh you know, not as bad as Queean just saying like, "I like null."
How is Destiny offering overt support less bad? >> Hold
on, let me explain. Let me explain. Hold on. Sure. >> So,
he gets the pass. The reason because is because he was currently
in a huge magnitude beef with Keles at the time. And Keeles was
the one that was misrepresenting
Kiwi Farms, right? And
constantly dating them.
>> I went the whole stream without doing that a single
time. 8 hours and 45 minutes into the stream and I get I was
pitching a perfect game today. I didn't leave myself muted one
time right at the end. They got me every time. Finish. Let me
finish. So, at the time when the drama was going down, obviously,
>> uh, what was I saying? [__] I don't even
remember what I was saying now.
I don't remember what I was saying at all. Destiny was beefing
against Keles and was trying to do a steel man for Kiwi Farms
at the time and trying to like defend Kiwi Farms against like
Keles. That is not the same whatsoever as Quman on his own time
on his own stream making an appeal towards Joshua Moon and Kiwi
Farms. These two things. Oh, I was just laughing that like did
you consider that Keeles and Desi that Desi was in a massive
beef with Keeles for why he like wouldn't follow this principle?
It's like, yeah, he's willy mad. He's willy will really mad.
So, he allowed to do whatever he want cuz he really mad. It's
like that's okay. I get Okay. Not identical situations. >> What
was saying about Kiwi Farms?
>> She She was basically Oh, yeah. They were doxing her.
They were sending pizza to like her house. Oh, she moved locations,
but then they kept on sending like food towards her, right? >> Okay.
Is that not what Is that not Hold on. Hold on. Is that not what
Destiny is saying about Kiwi Farms? about other people right
right now. >> What? He's saying that Kiwi Farms is like
sending pizza to someone's house or some to >> saying that
Kiwi Farms is doxing Hutch. Kiwi Farms is doxing Willie all of
these people. It's because of Jtock. It's because of Queenman.
That's what he's doing right now. He's doing what? He's doing
what you think. >> He has literally Okay. He has literally
not said that. And even if he did, I would just
>> Okay. So, he hasn't said that. But even if he did, so
hold on. You're saying you're saying you're paying food shops
and Facebook directly are organizing doxing. Okay. All right.
>> I'm not saying that. I don't think that's true. I don't
think there's any evidence for it. I'm saying that's what Destiny
is saying. >> Wait, wait. Yeah. I don't think Destiny said
that proof. >> Okay. Didn't he literally make a chart uh
saying like, okay, I would >> No, he now he rolled back
his claim. So, he said we were doing it before said our communities
were doxing communities. He said my community is a doxing community,
right? He said that. Oh, [__] I have it on my Twitter.
Hold on. Let me go see here. Uh, hold on. I'll I'll let this
play for a second. Back it up for >> Okay. Didn't he literally
make a chart uh saying like Okay, I would. Yeah. If someone has
a clip of that, send it to me. I'll forward it. >> Video
where everyone losing their mind that Destiny threatened to kill.
somebody because the I have like three communities on LSF that
are obsessively up down voting all my um people are I think I
don't even
months ago but somebody basically asked me I think Willie Mack
asked me something like oh like how do you feel about uh these
people whatever and I was like if you're somebody that is actively
engaged in a community that is like spam linking revenge of me
revenge uh docs of me docs of my girlfriend revenge my like if
you're doing all this [__] I stupid don't give a
[__] what happens to you if anything so that's the
claim if you're part of a community that does this and so the
claim the the the the question would be where's your evidence
that I'm a I'm that I've done any of this and that I'm a part
of any community that does this or whatever. I think that was
basically the gist of the question and these guys who are all
kind of like sliding
um they have no audiences and people like the fact that I'm even
saying this now is going to be the next like 15 hours of streams
for all these people um because they're like so desperately clinging
on to anything that they can talk about relating to me. They've
like uh latched on to this is like I'm trying to get them or
something. It's just like but yeah >> not saying >> yeah
so that is that was the linking revenge linking revenge docs
or docs of him docs of his friends right that I'm a part of communities
that do that that I am participate in communities that do that
that is not true so he's softened it back to like you participate
by reading and propagating somehow right he's totally softened
what his actual claim was he he's softened it way back now but
this was not his original claim so we should never let him get
away from this right these were the original
This man is like a disgusting liar. He's just making things up.
And then once he once he's sufficiently called out by people
for totally making things up, he has to change it. He has to
rewrite the story, right? It's all creative writing. It's all
fanfiction. And when he realizes people go, "Oh, well that's
not really believable." He's like, "Oh, well, I'll edit that.
Okay, I'll edit that a little bit."
>> Oh, we're done with this.
We're getting to the end of this guy, >> And what you're
saying is that Destiny said they explicitly organized doxing,
right? Uh I believe so something something along those lines
to the same effect. Obviously I don't know word for >> one
of the new soften claims that we don't participate directly.
We'd never be caught participating directly but we kind of wink
and nudge at these people. We kind of like wink at them. We like
do the same jokes or we speak the same way and so we're a part
of those communities in like spirit if not in actuality. Yeah.
I I I'm curious as to this. Okay. All right. I would love to
see this. >> Yeah. Sure. Kingler, you can say this, but
you always reset back to like defending Destiny, defending Destiny's
position, and you have to be convinced of why it's bad every
single time. So, I don't want you to say like I don't want you
to say that. By the way, Kingler is a part of our community,
okay? So, do not harass King or be mad at Kingler, but I'm just
saying that like you do always reset to like his precise position.
So, you could say that like you don't argue he's not guilty.
You argue like the things he's arguing at any given time. I've
never seen you default to be like, "Oh, that's a great
But anyway, uh, >> organizing doxing specifically, not
coordinating narrative against him. Yes, we're being very clear
on this. >> I believe I believe he is calling other people
doxers while explicitly trying to dox them when there's no evidence
that these people are doxing anyone else. >> Okay. Well,
I'm specifically talking about a claim, a very specific claim.
But okay, we'll see. >> I should probably send the tweet
to morale as well. Not that one. Sorry, did I close it? I did
close it. Okay. Not that one. Although, I should also send moral
that tweet.
Uh, okay. Yeah, I don't have proof for that claim. I don't care.
Engage with the question that I've been asking you for like 30
minutes now, please. I don't give a [__] about that.
>> Yeah, I'm not. Okay. Yeah, sure. You can you can do
your whole victory roll. Why does Destiny get a pass and Quimman
>> Unless you want to sit here for like 5 minutes and wait
for someone to send me a clip. Okay. And she just left. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't know what you guys want. I'm not
going to sit there for >> Yeah. I'm I'm sorry. At least
in the dickers thing, it looks like it's kind of calculated that
she's trying not to engage and she's just like muddying the waters
and she doesn't look in this one. It's clear she just doesn't
understand. She like can't pay attention, right? This one makes
food jobs look way worse, I think. Not because Dickers didn't
do a good job, but just because like it's like a calculated decision
not to engage in the other one and like Yeah.
um yeah. Yeah, sure. Kingler. Uh it's Kingler. What it could
be as well is um if you agree with me, you just don't type in
chat, right? So, it could just be like confirmation bias because
you're probably not really typing very much if you agree. So,
>> yeah, apologize to Kingler. Yeah, >> I just said
what it could be. Okay, that's it for us, guys. We're done. Stream
is done. 9 hours. Quick 9 hours. Lightweight 9 hours stream out
of nowhere. Isn't it funny how I just get told I'm just emotional
because I was friends with Destiny and Kingler doesn't.
Kingler wasn't friends with Destiny. Kingler didn't know Destiny.
Dude, Jtock,
>> what's up? How's it going? >> Did you see the
Doomer Media's book? >> dude. He put your docs on Twitter.
>> No, he didn't. >> No, I'm like, no, I'm not joking.
You want me to I can send you the tweet?
>> Yeah, sure.
>> this is like crazy. >> No, this has to be a joke.
Send me two. Send me two moral. >> I'll pull it up on stream,
I'm sure. Look at this. >> You're I'm not pulling it up
on stream. What are you doing? >> Yeah, you got What do
you What did he actually send you? >> Mau sent me this.
He sent me this. Let >> Wait, why is the at not changed
for you? What the [__] God damn it. >> Oh,
yeah. Sorry. The at is Oh, the Cuz the URL was like Doomer Media,
but it showed up. So, he put he put Doomer Media in the URL,
but all Twitter checks is the number to >> No, I have the
at now. >> Oh, you do have the at now? >> Yeah, I'm
at Doomer Media on Twitter.
>> He's lost.
>> Cool. Now, this is this is like crazy
crazy.
I feel like I'm like holding out hope that we just win. We're
like in the right completely. Like I've never been more certain
that I'm correct on ever like on something like this ever, right?
There's it's not even really subjective. We're just correct.
We're in the right. We are the righteous party in this in this
affair, right? Like Destiny has totally abandoned his principles.
He is just harassing people. He's a total like totally deranged
loser, right? You should open that screenshot tweet. This one.
Wait, which one? Wait, which one? Neosick. The green pepper one.
>> The green pepper one. >> Steumer coming back.
He's coming back. He's on his way back.
>> Um, yeah. I just think like we're we're just totally
correct. Like uh this is like unhinged. It's just insane. Like
all lies. It's all lies and like nobody's talking about it. I
just feel like surely there has to be some harm. Surely Destiny
hasn't just like transparently like obviously lied about other
people in the same way. I like I think there were major mistakes
with Max, but I guess I make mistakes too. I don't know. I feel
like this has got to be it that if you just don't go away, keep
showing that he's like totally unhinged.
I don't know. Yeah, I don't know, man. I don't know. Like hopefully
hopefully we'll see. Hopefully. All right.
Anyway, thank you moral for showing me that you have the doomerat
the other the picture.
Thank you. Cool. Cool, cool, cool. All right, I think we're we're
done here. I'm going to see who's on. See if I'm raiding somebody.
Host a channel. Host a channel. Host a channel. We're going to
host a channel. I'll definitely host Really cuz he's online.
Go say hi to Really, guys. And I'm out. So, we'll talk to you'all
later. Thanks for being here. Have a good night and I'll be back
tomorrow, I think. Yeah, I'll be back tomorrow. I still have
all the Zena content that we haven't gone through, like Zena's
arrest and the from tonight. So, we'll be able to go through
all of that tomorrow. be all the content tomorrow. It'll be awesome.
Again, we'll be back even more scavenger hunt highlights. Maybe
some updates on Lav and Gooner and ice and everything that's
going on there. We'll see how it goes. Okay, so I'll be back.
Love you guys. Have a good night.